Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge numéro 48. 48. Viele werden sich sicherlich wundern, dass wir es tatsächlich schaffen, 2020 eine Rekordzahl von Sendungen aufzunehmen, nehme ich die vierte dieses Jahr. Das haben wir schon viele Jahre nicht geschafft, ich habe mal nachgeguckt, ich glaube seit 2013 nicht.
Na ja, eigentlich ist ja unser Ziel, nicht mehr Sendungen zu haben, als wir Lebensalter in Jahren haben, oder? Wird jetzt ein bisschen dünner. Wir versuchen das schon immer, aber was wird zu machen im Lockdown? Und irgendwie waren wir auch ausgelastet mit Covid. Aber es gibt noch andere Themen und eines von denen wollen wir heute mit euch besprechen.
Ja, also die Überschrift, die wir haben, ist eigentlich so, Cyberpunk ist now, am Ende.
Sowohl Cyberpunk als auch Cyberpunk.
Das stimmt.
Ja, zwei nahe Konzepte.
Ja. Und wir wollten natürlich nicht irgendwie auf das, allzu sehr auf die Kontroverse mit dem gerade laufenden Spiel eingehen. Ich hätt mir das eigentlich für nächstes Jahr auf, wenn die Bugs gefixt sind.
Och, ich hab das schon gezockt, bin sehr zufrieden.
Okay.
Naja, aber es ist ganz lustig, wie so virtuelle Geschichten und Filme und Bücher es manchmal schaffen, die Perspektive auf die Welt so ein bisschen zu ändern. Und das ist mir bei diesem Game auch ein bisschen so gegangen. Ich weiß jetzt kein neues Szenario, was die da haben, aber so ist es im Wesentlichen das alte Cyberpunk-Szenario von dem Rollenspiel, dass die Leute alle mit irgendwelchen Implantaten rumlaufen, die sie dann irgendwie schneller, besser, stärker machen und so weiter. Und die Politik ist auf dem Rückzug und spielt praktisch keine Rolle mehr. Die Macht liegt bei den MegaCorps, wie das halt ist im Cyberpunk. Und das wirkt alles noch nicht so nah, bis man sich denkt, ja, wie, warte mal, also wir haben zwar keine Implantate, aber wir laufen alle mit irgendwie Bluetooth-Ohrstöpseln rum und mit einer Smartwatch und einem Computer in der Tasche, der als Peilsender fungiert. Alles ist hackbar. Ja, es gibt irgendwie eine App, die dir sagt, mit der das Telefon dann irgendwie Leute wiedererkennt oder dir sagen kann, was das für eine Baumart ist, die du gerade mit der Linse filmst. Das heißt, eigentlich haben wir das schon, es sind nur keine Implantate geworden in unserer Realität, sondern es sind Sachen, die wir mit uns rumtragen. Aber wenn du mal drauf achtest, wie lang der typische Smartphone-Benutzer sein Gerät zur Seite legen kann, ohne damit zu interagieren, dann ist das eigentlich schon ein Implantat. Also so von der von der Nähe her. Ich würde sogar sagen, im Spiel hast du längere Zeiten, wo du mal irgendwie die bionischen Beine nicht benutzt, als es in der Realität Zeiten gibt, wo die Leute ihr Smartphone nicht benutzen. Also das war alles sehr, sehr nah dran, fand ich, an der Realität. So und da ist dann auch mal ein bisschen anders auf die Realität geguckt.
Und diese die Rolle der MegaCorps und die Interaktion mit dem Staat, wie ist die da abgebildet?
Naja, also das Spiel spielt im Wesentlichen in einer Stadt, aber die ist, es gab Corporate Wars in der in der Timeline vor dem Spiel und die Stadt ist als eines der wenigen Relikte übriggeblieben, als eine Free City. Aber der Bürgermeister ist irgendwie gerade gestürzt oder so ist jedenfalls weg und der Nachfolger der Wahlkampf ist so ein bisschen Teil des Spiels. Aber alle Seiten sind korrupt und keiner von denen kann oder will irgendwas tun. Die Polizei ist korrupt. Es gibt keine Strukturen im Wesentlichen, auf die du dich verlassen kannst. Einer der Injokes ist, dass eins der Viertel von dem Bürgermeister als nicht Teil der Stadt deklariert wurde, damit die Kriminalitätsstatistik runtergeht und er im Wahlkampf gut aussieht. Also, es gibt zwar einen Staat, aber im Wesentlichen ist als wäre der Staat nicht da. Es gibt natürlich große Ungleichheit, wie auch in der realen Jetztzeit. Also ich fand den Abstand an einigen Stellen unangenehm klein. Aber so formuliert. Ja, aber es geht ja nicht nur um so Politik bei Cyberpunk, sondern es geht natürlich auch um Perspektiven. Bewegen wir uns gerade in die Richtung hin? Sind wir vielleicht schon verdammt weit in die Richtung gegangen? Ist das eine Dystopie oder ist das eher eine Warnung? Und ja, das ist eigentlich ganz spannend, sich unter dem Blickwinkel mal die aktuellen Konflikte und Politikfragen anzugucken.
Naja, was mich so das letzte Jahr eigentlich auch gerade im Zusammenhang damit, wie jetzt diese Corona-Hilfen gelaufen sind, immer stärker bewegt ist eben diese Frage, welche Rolle spielt eigentlich der Staat gerade wirklich? Also jetzt nicht irgendwie, was jetzt seinen Anspruch oder seine PR angeht, sondern welche Rolle spielt er wirklich? Und wie ist halt sein Verhältnis zu den tatsächlichen MegaCorps, die wir haben, und den anderen Unternehmen? Und wo läuft das eigentlich als Struktur für die Gesellschaft gerade hin? Und für mich ist ja immer so die Frage, wovor hat so ein Staat eigentlich Angst? Also was ist irgendwie sein Treiber, seine Motivation? Und was will er eigentlich positiv? Und da gibt es natürlich dann halt von den Leuten, die halt irgendwie, sollen wir noch einen relativ naiven Glauben an die Funktionsfähigkeit der demokratischen Systeme haben, immer so die Antwort, ja, na, wenn es dir nicht gefällt, dann musst du halt in die Politik gehen, um es zu ändern. Und ganz ehrlich, das erinnert mich mittlerweile so ein bisschen so an diese... So in der DDR gab es das halt auch, da gab es halt dieses irgendwie so, ja, wenn du was ändern willst, dann musst du halt Genosse werden, dann musst du halt irgendwie Teil des Systems werden, um halt irgendwie die Veränderung von innen herbeizuführen. So, und das ist halt so für mich halt irgendwie so gerade so die, so ein bisschen die Frage, wenn man so auf all die ganzen Konfliktfelder guckt, die wir gerade haben, mit den, sagen wir mal, wieder wichtiger werdenden, ich würde das nicht sagen, erstarkenden, aber wichtiger werdenden an der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung nationalstaaten. So wir hatten jetzt wieder mal Grenzschließungen, also wo halt einfach irgendwie die Staaten gesagt haben, so jetzt ist halt irgendwie die Grenze geschlossen, so und wir werden es wahrscheinlich wieder haben, so wie es gerade aussieht. Wir haben irgendwie massive Einschränkungen irgendwie im Reiseverkehr gehabt und die werden wahrscheinlich so schnell auch nie weggehen. Und die Auseinandersetzung um die Impfstoffe ist ja auch eher sehr nationalistisch. Also Deutschland versucht natürlich immer noch so ein bisschen so das europäische Pfeifen im dunklen Wald zu machen und irgendwie zu sagen, ja, aber wir müssen ja irgendwie eine europäische Lösung finden und das alle irgendwie gemeinsam machen so, was technisch gesehen natürlich vollkommen richtig ist, weil Europa ist nochmal ein integriertes System mit relativ vor Integration von Personenbewegungen. Also schon aus rein epidemiologischer Sicht macht es natürlich Sinn, eine europäische Lösung zu finden. Aber wenn man sich dann mal anguckt, wie die Stimmung so ist, wenn du jetzt heute auf der Straße fragen würdest, okay, nehmen wir mal an, irgendwie Deutschland hat 500 Millionen Impfdosen, sollten wir davon was abgeben oder sollten wir erstmal unsere eigene Bevölkerung impfen? Ich wette, die Antwort wäre 70 oder 90 Prozent der Leute würden sagen, wir impfen natürlich erstmal uns alleine. Und dann gucken wir mal, wie es den anderen so geht.
Wobei bei uns noch dazu kommt, dass der Impfstoff ja sozusagen bei uns erfunden wurde. Das ändert, glaube ich, die Perspektive auch ein bisschen. Wenn du jemand wärst wie die USA, die also komplett im Grunde angewiesen sind auf Fremdforschung, wobei dieses moderne Ding, das kam, glaube ich, aus den USA, oder? Wie war das? Wo kam das her?
Weiß ich nicht mehr so genau. Das ist alles relativ im Zeitpunkt.
Also die Amis haben ja im Wesentlichen die Strategie gefahren, naja, wir bieten dann halt einen guten Preis und dann werden wir uns schon durchsetzen gegen die ganzen Schlucker. Ja, und waren regelrecht geschockt, als dann andere Länder meinten, naja, wir verkaufen euch ein paar Millionen Dosen, aber es gibt auch anderswo Leute, die gern geimpft werden wollen. Das war, glaube ich, so ein richtiger Realitätsschock. Und apropos Realitätsschock, ich muss sagen, diese Grenzschließung hat mich schärfer mitgenommen, als ich gedacht habe, obwohl ich überhaupt nicht betroffen war. Ich wollte nicht mal ausreisen, aber die Idee, dass einem dieses Schengen wieder weggenommen wird, fand ich deutlich bedrückender, als ich vorher gedacht hätte. Ich finde die Sache zwischen Staaten ist zwar wichtig, aber mir ist es erst mal wichtiger innerhalb der Staaten, denn da gibt es ja eigentlich so zwei große Konfliktfelder. Es gibt einmal so Regulierungsbehörden und Kartellämter. Das sind eigentlich die beiden mit, also natürlich so Umweltschutzauflagen und so weiter, Arbeitsrecht. Aber so die beiden Arten von Behörden, die tatsächlich verantwortlich dafür sind, große Firmen daran zu hindern, Mist zu machen, sind ja so die beiden im Wesentlichen. Du hast irgendwie sowas wie die BaFin, die soll die Versicherungen und Banken ehrlich halten. Und du hast halt das Kartellamt, was verhindern soll, dass sich Monopole bilden, die nicht natürlichen Ursprungs sind, sondern irgendwie Marktausnutzung. Und wenn du dir anguckst, was die gemacht haben in den letzten Jahren, dann siehst du bei den Regulierungsbehörden eigentlich ein weitgehendes Versagen. Jetzt gab es diesen Wirecard-Skandal, der hat gezeigt, dass die BaFin im Wesentlichen nichts getan hat, nicht nur nichts getan, sondern Personal von denen hat mitgezockt. Wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab. Also es war eigentlich total Schaden für die BaFin, der Wirecard-Skandal. Und das Kartellamt wird, also jedenfalls so wie es sich anfühlt, als Profit-Center betrieben. Wenn die irgendwie einen Fall sehen, wo man vielleicht Google mal eine Milliardenstrafe reindrücken kann, dann ist das schon opportun, das mal zu machen. Aber so wirklich was verhindert haben die ja nicht. Die letzten Jahre gab es ja sozusagen kostenlos Geld, weil irgendwie die Antwort auf die Wirtschaftskrise war, wir pumpen einfach Geld in den Markt. Das heißt, große Firmen konnten für kleine Zinsen große Kredite aufnehmen und damit ihre Konkurrenten kaufen. Und da hat das Kartellamt so gut wie nichts von verhindert. Dabei ist es eigentlich immer nachteilig für den Konsumenten, wenn sich große Firmen zusammen fusionieren. Das heißt, das Gesamtgefühl ist, dass es so eine große... Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt Schwäche ist oder vielleicht ist es auch Korruption. Man weiß es ja nicht. Vielleicht ist es ja Absicht, dass die Behörden schwach sind. Aber das Gefühl, dass der Staat mich vor den Firmen schützt, habe ich ja schon länger nicht mehr. Aber so ausgeprägt wie jetzt war es eigentlich auch noch nie.
Naja, ich meine, was wir da halt haben, heißt halt regulatory capture. Das heißt also, die...
Genau, erklär das doch mal. Das ist ein Konzept, das ist mir erst vor ein paar Jahren zum ersten Mal begegnet.
Ja, also regulatory capture ist halt ein Konzept, das sagt, ab einem bestimmten Punkt von Komplexität und von Größe von wirtschaftlicher Erflechtung ist es für Unternehmen hochprofitabel, die Regulierung des Staates auszunutzen zu ihrem Vorteil. Und da gibt es halt mehrere Spielarten von so. Es gibt halt irgendwie so den Teil, den wir jetzt gerade sehen, der ist im Wesentlichen, man macht die Regulierung so komplex und teuer, sie einzuhalten, dass nur noch große Unternehmen in der Lage sind, das zu tun, die halt irgendwie eine Rechtsabteilung haben für regulatorische Prozesse und so weiter. Und das sind dann halt häufig dieselben Großkanzleien, die für diese Großunternehmen arbeiten, die wiederum die möglichst komplexen Regeln schreiben, sei es zum Steuer umgehen oder sei es halt irgendwie, um Subventionen zu bekommen. Also wenn du jetzt anguckst, an wen gingen halt die ganzen Corona-Hilfen? Die gingen natürlich nicht an die kleinen Unternehmen, die es halt gebraucht hätten, so die gingen selbstverständlich an die Großunternehmen zum großen Teil. Die eigene Behörden dafür haben, sich um solche Subventionskram zu kümmern. Eine andere Spielart ist, dass man unter dem Mantel von anderen Regulierungen, zum Beispiel Umweltschutz, Gleichberechtigung, was auch immer, Dinge tut, die dazu führen, dass die generelle Cost of Doing Business, also zu sagen, generell, was muss ich denn alles tun, wenn ich in einem bestimmten Bereich unterwegs sein will und irgendwie Sachen tun will, nach oben getrieben wird? Am liebsten kombiniert mit sogenannten Grandfathering-Regelungen, nämlich, dass man sagt, ja, Firmen, die jetzt schon in dem Markt sind und die jetzt sich schon bestimmte Sachen angewöhnt haben, denen können wir jetzt natürlich nicht irgendwie dieses oder jenes verbieten, weil das wäre ja eine Marktverzerrung. Aber jeder, der jetzt neu da reinkommt und neu da anfängt, der muss halt irgendwie sich an die neun tollen Regeln für Umweltschutz, what not, irgendwie halten, so. Und der Effekt davon ist halt, dass der, ja, also die Möglichkeit, neue Markte zu erschließen oder auch einfach komplett neue Dinge zu tun und sich halt zu versuchen, irgendwie neu als Unternehmen oder auch als einzelnen Personen in solche Markte reinzubegeben, halt immer schwieriger wird und die also gerade so übertriebene Regulierungen halt dazu führen, dass du halt eine Markteintrittsbarriere hast, auch was irgendwie die Mengen an Kapital, mit der du halt antreten musst, angeht, das halt immer schwieriger wird, halt da überhaupt irgendwas zu tun. Und dann hast du halt, also ein zum Beispiel war zum Beispiel die die Auseinandersetzung um E-Zigaretten und Vaping in den USA, weil es gerade ein sehr schönes Beispiel von Regulatory Capture, wo einzelne Unternehmen den zeitweise erfolgreichen Versuch unternommen haben, bis sie dann halt durch einen Skandal gekippt sind. Das war Jul in dem Fall. Die haben halt gesagt, es ist okay, wir wollen halt möglichst harte Regeln für E-Zigaretten. Und alle haben zugestimmt, weil irgendwie Kinderschutz, Jugendschutz, irgendwie Gesundheitsvorsorge und so weiter und so fort. Und damit haben die halt relativ erfolgreich einen Großteil von kleineren Konkurrenten platt gemacht, die da halt einfach nicht mithalten konnten. Also die halt nicht in der Lage waren, halt irgendwie in dem Bereich halt irgendwas zu tun. Gut, ich meine, in dem Bereich ist nicht weiter schlimm, wenn es halt irgendwie zu weniger, sagen wir, Wildwuchs gibt und irgendwie die Skandale, die die da jetzt da hatten, mit irgendwie Zusatzmitteln in diesen E-Zigaretten, die halt irgendwie die Leute teilweise schwer krank gemacht haben, haben natürlich gezeigt, dass man da halt auch gewisse Mindeststandards setzen muss. Aber dieser Prozess, wie man da hinkommt und wer diese Regeln schreibt, wer die Folgekosten für solche regulatorischen Innovationen evaluiert, das ist natürlich in der Regel dann so, da gibt es halt irgendwie ein paar Experten an dem Feld. Die Experten arbeiten bei den Großkonslädern, den Beratungsunternehmen, die arbeiten für die großen Unternehmen. Die haben halt wiederum halt irgendwie einen Incentive, irgendwie bestimmte Regeln zu verhindern oder durchzudrücken, je nachdem, wie sie sich gerade aufgestellt haben. Das heißt, dieser gesamte Prozess, wie solche Regeln halt irgendwie eingeführt werden und irgendwie erfunden werden und so weiter und so fort, ist halt schon gecaptchert. Also der befindet sich halt schon nicht mehr im Bereich von irgendwie, es gibt da politische Experten, die halt irgendwie sich da so gut auskennen, dass sie halt solche Regeln selber schreiben können und irgendwie absehen können, was die Risiken und Nebenwirkungen sind und was es halt irgendwie einen Marktkonzentrationseffekt haben wird und so weiter. Sondern die haben halt externe Berater und diese externe Berater haben dann halt irgendwie natürlich irgendwie mehr als eine Trasse, die halt irgendwie da diese Regeln halt irgendwie zu formen. Und das sehen wir jetzt halt überall, in allen Bereichen. So es hat keinen, es fällt gerade wirklich echt keinen Bereich mehr ein, wo es halt nicht so ist, bis hinein zum Umweltschutz. Und das ist halt so eine Situation, wo für mich sicher die Frage stellt, ob diese Vision von wir machen das Leben besser und schöner, indem wir immer mehr Regeln erfinden, die den bösen Unternehmen verbieten, Dinge zu tun, ob die überhaupt noch valide ist. Also ob das überhaupt noch ein, sagen wir mal so, ein Weg in die Zukunft ist, der halt irgendwie funktionieren kann, oder ob man da halt nicht noch mal grundsätzlich neu anfangen muss und sagen muss, okay, vielleicht sollten wir uns darüber unterhalten, dass einfach jede Regel Folgen und Kosten und Nebenwirkungen hat. Und wir bestimmte Sachen vielleicht doch einfach erstmal ausprobieren sollten, also als Experiment deklarieren sollten und dann mal evaluieren sollten und nicht einfach quasi, wie wir nehmen jetzt mal die Gesetze, damit wir irgendwie möglichst viel, bzw. Gesetzesvorhaben aus den entsprechenden Beraterunternehmen und Kanzleien und sorgen denn dafür, dass sie möglichst schnell durchkommen, damit es so aussieht, als wenn die Regierung was tut.
Also es ist nicht alles so negativ, wie du es jetzt darstellst. Es gibt auch die Innenansicht, dass Leute ohne Berater regulatory capture haben, weil es dann natürlich eine Drehtür gibt zwischen der Industrie. Also wer soll denn bitte in der Bankenaufsicht die Banken kontrollieren, wenn nicht Banker, die sich mit der Scheiße auskennen. Und natürlich gibt es da eine Drehtür. Das heißt, dass die Leute, die heute die Gesetze machen, die kriegen dann morgen Aufsichtsratposten in irgendeiner großen Bank.
Wolltest du nicht gerade irgendwas erzählen, was nicht so negativ ist?
Nein, also ich meine, das ist ja dann nicht unbedingt böse gemeint, sondern die haben halt im Hinterkopf auch die Perspektive aus Sicht der zu regulierenden Firmen und sehen sich selbst in der Situation. Es ist also nicht so, dass es da irgendwie unbedingt... Na gut, man kann natürlich auch sagen, es ist einfach Korruption. Ach so, eine andere Sache, die ich noch kurz erwähnen wollte, am Rand Grandfather Clause. Der Begriff kommt aus den Rassistengesetzen aus den USA. Das ist eine Sache, die ich vor ein paar Jahren mal rausgefunden habe. Und die ich seitdem einfach jedes Mal im Hinterkopf habe, wenn ich davon höre. Und zwar war die Idee, dass die Jim Crow Gesetze heißen, die wollten gern verhindern, dass die Schwarzen Einfluss auf die Politik nehmen können. Und zwar haben die also auf dem Papier Gleichberechtigung bekommen, aber man wollte verhindern in einigen rassistischen Südstaaten besonders stark, dass die tatsächlich wählen können. Und dann hat man ein Wahlregister eingeführt und gesagt, du darfst nur wählen, wenn du registriert bist. Und dafür musst du halt lesen und schreiben können. Und das konnten die halt nicht. Damit waren die ausgeschlossen. Aber so die alten Weißen konnten es auch nicht. Und für die hat man gesagt, na ja, das ist der Großvater. Die Ausnahme für die alten Weißen, damit die weiter wählen dürfen, das ist der ursprüngliche Grandfather-Clause. Und aus der Perspektive sehen die aktuellen Grandfather-Clause ganz anders aus, weil das ist selben gut. Es gibt noch ein Gegenstück zu Grandfather-Clause und zwar den Sunset-Clause, dass man sagt, wir machen jetzt ein Gesetz, weil du das gerade erwähnt hast, wir machen ein Gesetz, um was auszuprobieren. Da gibt es ein Konzept für, dass du das Gesetz machst und da steht drin, das gilt jetzt für ein Jahr und danach fällt es automatisch hinten runter, außer wir verlängern es nochmal. Das heißt, dass der Blick auf das Gesetz ist gar nicht, okay, das ist jetzt das Gesetz, sondern wir probieren jetzt mal, bringst du damit zum Ausdruck. Es bringt leider nicht viel, das wird in Amerika häufiger gemacht. Es bringt leider nicht viel, die meisten Gesetze werden einfach bestätigt, weil keiner will gern Fehler zugeben und Gesetze nicht nochmal zu verlängern. Der Patriot Act hatte sowas zum Beispiel auch und ist einfach halt trotzdem verlängert worden. Aber das ist ein generelles Problem. Es gibt zumindest diesen Ansatz und nicht mal den machen wir bei uns.
Ja, egal ob es jetzt so ein... Also, nee, andersrum. Wenn man Sachen ausprobieren will, dann muss man nicht alle davon immer gleich auf europäischer oder gesamtdeutscher Ebene ausprobieren. Also, es ist halt schon so, dass halt irgendwie die, sagen wir mal, bestimmte Wirkung und Nebenwirkungen von Regeln, insbesondere wenn sie halt in komplexen Gebieten sind, kann man auch mal Lokale ausprobieren. Also wo man halt einfach sagt, okay, es gibt halt irgendwie keine Ahnung. Wir sagen halt für bestimmte Industrien oder bestimmte Anwendungsfälle, gibt es halt Bundesländer, die halt irgendwie Experimentierfelder sind. Also wo man dann sagt, okay, keine Ahnung, wir führen in diesem Bundesland hier mal, nehmen wir mal an, die nehmen wir in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, wir führen da jetzt mal irgendwie eine Regel ein für keine Ahnung. Oder wir probieren die Regel aus, dass irgendwie Internetprovider sich bestimmten Regeln unterwerfen müssen. Nehmen wir mal an, keine Ahnung, Entfernung von Hatepostings. Und dann kann man ja mal gucken, wie es in dem Bundesland so läuft. Wenn man sieht, dass die sich plötzlich alle woanders hinbewegen, dann möglicherweise ratet der einen einen Grund. Also das ist so, oder gut, ich weiß, vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel bei Internet, aber ich glaube, dass wir halt auch bei dieser Corona-Nummer in die Falle gelaufen sind, dass Politiker inzwischen der Ansicht sind, dass man der Öffentlichkeit nicht vermitteln kann, dass bestimmte Sachen ein Experiment sind. Also es ist halt so dieses, wir müssen irgendwie einheitliche Regeln, es muss überall das gleiche sein, es muss halt immer alles gleich sein. Ist aus meiner Sicht ein grober Fehler. Weil selbstverständlich haben wir in Deutschland irgendwie eine Vielfalt von lokalen Unterschiedlichkeiten, anderen Regeln und so weiter und so fort. Und die Leute sind ja auch stolz darauf. Natürlich kann man auch mal ausprobieren, wie bestimmte Sachen sich halt auswirken. Also wie man hätte ja zum Beispiel einfach mal anstatt da rumzueiern sagen können, okay, wir probieren das halt einfach mal aus. Vier Wochen lang mit irgendwie Schulschließungen in irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Bremen oder so. Ja, und dann gucken wir mal, was da passiert. So wie viel Auswirkungen hat es denn? Oder wir probieren halt einfach mal aus, wie viel bringt dann halt eine Maskenpflicht in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln in, keine Ahnung, Nordrhein-Westfalen oder so und dann und sagt halt, okay, das ist jetzt vier Wochen. Und wenn wir sehen, das bringt was, dann machen wir das bundesweit. Und wenn das nix bringt, dann machen wir das halt aus. So, nächstes Mal ist ein anderes Bundesland dran.
Also ich fürchte, du erzeugst damit einen Markt für Abitrage-Geschäfte, wie man das so schön nennt. Ja, dann fliegt halt der südafrikanische Tourist über Wien ein, was wir jetzt gerade als Meldung hatten, weil der Dir-Direkt-Einflug nach Deutschland ging halt nicht. Und dann suchst du dir halt ein anderes Bundesland oder in dem Fall halt ein anderes Land.
Geht halt nicht für alles. Also klar ist halt, man muss sich das halt schon genau überlegen. Aber ich habe halt so den Eindruck, dass diese Überlegung findet halt nicht mehr statt. Und auch dieses Wissen darum, dass halt mehr Regeln nicht gleich mehr gut ist, sondern halt irgendwie mehr Regeln, halt in der Regel erst mal heißt, dass man mehr Nebenwirkungen hat. Das ist, glaube ich, so ein Ding, das haben die halt alle vergessen. Das ist halt irgendwie so eine...
Ich glaube, das ist ihr ein PR-Problem. In einer Krise ist eigentlich traditionell die PR-Chance für die Politik. Die Elbe Flut hat den Schröder gerettet damals. Alle Politiker, alle Politiker.
Spahn ist der beliebteste Politiker?
Ja, genau.
Ich meine, gut, es war eine Umfrage von einem Umfrageninstitut, von dem ich noch nie gehört habe, für die Bild an Sonntag. Okay, möglicherweise ist das halt auch alle sowieso gekauft. Aber diese Aussage, dass er beliebter sei als Merkel, ich meine...
Was?
Ich meine, wenn wir einen Vollfall sagen, dieser ganzen Corona-Krise haben dann ja wohl diesen Typen.
Ja, also ich würde da jetzt keinen Einzelnen rausziehen wollen, weil die sich alle nicht mehr drum bekämpfen haben.
Der ist einfach mal verantwortlich. Der ist der Gesundheitsminister. Der ist nach dem Infektionsschutzgesetz der Inhaber, der macht über all diesen ganzen Dinge.
Okay, ich möchte das nicht im Record haben, dass ich Spahn verteidigt habe an dieser Stelle. Ich möchte hier mal ganz klar sagen. Aber der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, ist, in einer Krise als Politiker hast du eigentlich nur einen Auftrag, nämlich so auszusehen, als wüsstest du, was getan werden muss und das zu machen. Das heißt, ich glaube, es gibt ein fundamentales Problem, damit in einer Krise so zu tun, als müssten wir jetzt Sachen ausprobieren, weil das eine Eingeständnis von Schwäche ist und das will keiner von denen haben. Ich glaube auch, dass das mit den, so ein Bundesland-Test mal nach hinten losgehen würde, wenn du dir anguckst, was das Medienecho war, auf die Schulschließung war. Fast alle haben als Erste draufgehauen, dass das nicht bundesweit einheitlich war, sondern dass jedes Land da irgendwas gewurstet hat. Und das wurde auch als Zeichen der Schwäche gesehen. Ich glaube, in Krisen geht es tatsächlich der Politik nur darum, irgendwie stark auszusehen. So beruhigt euch Leute, wir kriegen das hin. Ja, und dazu kannst du halt nicht gleichzeitig als Botschaft bringen, wir testen jetzt mal was.
Na gut, ich meine, inzwischen haben wir genug Wissen. Inzwischen wissen wir auch, dass Schulschließung tatsächlich eine Menge bringt. So wir wollten es nur nicht wahrhaben. Also wir haben ja sozusagen diese Dualität von einerseits vermeiden des Aufbauens von Wissen, indem halt bestimmte Studien nicht durchgeführt werden. Also siehe zum Beispiel halt systematische Studien, welche Maßnahmen bringen tatsächlich wie viel, welche, was sind Verbreitungswege. Ich meine, wenn du dir anguckst, was die da an lächerlichem Kram zusammengeklickt haben, wo sie einfach nur versagt haben, um diese Informationen zu erheben. Also für mich hat halt dieser Staat in dieser Corona-Krise in einem Ausmaß Inkompetenz, Dummheit und ich muss mal schon fast sagen, fast kriminelle Unfähigkeit bewiesen, die so nicht erwartet hätte. Also ich meine, ich stehe diesem Staat ja ohnehin schon per se kritisch gegenüber.
Aber eigentlich war es so, dass vielleicht ab jetzt ist der ganze Staat.
Ja, ich meine, sagen wir mal so, ich hatte halt einfach durchaus auch den Anspruch oder hab den eigentlich immer noch zu sagen, okay, wir versuchen irgendwie Dinge besser zu machen. So nur wenn man dann halt, also wenn du halt so auf der einen Seite siehst, okay, mit dem Infektionsschutzgesetz haben die eine unglaubliche Machtkonstitution. Also ist halt so auf der Spinner Seite, wo du es halt immer irgendwie als Ermächtigungsgesetz bezeichnet. Und wenn du das so liest, dann kannst du durchaus das Gefühl bekommen. Also das ist halt so schon so krass. Was können die alles machen? Was können die alles anordnen? Auf der anderen Seite hast du dann kombiniert aber eine völlige Unfähigkeit zu begründen, warum man jetzt irgendwas tut. Und die meisten Leute sind ja zufrieden, wenn sie irgendeine Begründung haben, die nicht offensichtlicher Bullshit ist. Also wenn man sagt, okay, wir machen dieses, um dieses Ziel zu erreichen. Und hinterher werden wir sehen, ob was dabei rausgekommen ist. Kann jeder aber irgendwie was mit anfangen, mit irgendwie so einer logischen Kette so. Und stattdessen verfallen die auf so eine AfD-Rhetorik von wegen so strikte Maßnahmen, harte Maßnahmen, so das war quasi schon so eine Eskalation von Adjektiven in der Beschreibung von Maßnahmen, als wenn irgendwie Dinge, die möglichst unbequem sind, jetzt auch möglichst doll gegen Corona helfen, was schlicht nicht der Fall ist.
Ich würde das nicht an Corona festmachen wollen, denn bei mir zumindest ist das ein, naja, wie nennt man das, ein slippery slope. Ich habe jetzt die letzten Jahre im Grunde beobachtet, wie eigentlich alle Regulierungsbehörden der Reihe nach voll verkackt haben. Also der Diesel-Skandal hat gezeigt, die Regulierungsbehörde, die uns vor kriminellen Autobauern schützen soll, ist eine Lachnummer. Wirecard hat gezeigt, die Regulierungsbehörde, die uns vor irgendwie Finanzbeschiss retten soll, ist eine Lachnummer. Dann sogar die privatwirtschaftliche zweite irgendwie Fallback-Schutzgeschichte über die Wirtschaftsprüfer ist eine Lachnummer. Jetzt sehen wir bei Covid, dass auch noch der Medizin-Teil irgendwie nicht so gut aussieht. Was bleibt denn da? Was fällt dir denn ein? Vorher die Regulation für Internet war im Wesentlichen betrieben von dem Innenminister, der irgendwie findet, wir brauchen mehr Abhörern und wir müssen Trojaner verteilen dürfen. Also mir fällt gerade keine einzige Regulierungsbehörde ein, von der ich sagen könnte, okay, ich habe den Eindruck, die tut ihre Arbeit und da sind Leute, die wissen, was sie tun. Und in dem Kontext, wenn jetzt auch noch Covid verkackt wird, dann fehlt mir einfach der, wie nenne ich das mal, Vorschussvertrauen. Da habe ich dann halt nicht mehr.
Grundvertrauen.
Genau. Also ich habe einfach kein Grundvertrauen, dass der Spahn da irgendwas fixt. Das heißt, ich sehe auch seine Maßnahmen viel kritischer von vorneherein. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was hier das fast zum Überlauf gebracht hat. Der hätte damit durchkommen können, wenn die Leute gesagt hätten, der ist halt der Gesundheitsminister, der macht jetzt hier mal. Der hätte auch mit dem total verkackten durchkommen können, meiner Ansicht nach, wenn es ein Restvertrauen in den Staat gegeben hätte, was aber im Wesentlichen über die letzten Jahre abgebaut wurde. Ja, also ich erinnere mich jetzt, fällt dir noch eine Regierungsbehörde ein, wo du sagen würdest, ja, die Telekommunikation erzählt uns seit 20 Jahren, dass wir bald Breitband in Brandenburg haben. Es gibt doch keine einzige Regierungsbehörde, wo du sagen würdest, okay, gut, dass wir die haben.
Also außerhalb von Berlin höre ich tatsächlich davon, dass es irgendwie lokale Behörden gibt, die okay sind und gut funktionieren so. In Berlin, ich glaube, das können wir mal als Sonderfall ausklappern.
Ich meinte eher so Bundesbehörden, ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, weil jetzt so, da ging mein Weg jetzt gerade hin.
Ja gut, also da wollte ich auch nicht argumentieren wollen, dass Berlin jetzt irgendwo vorbildlich ist.
Ja, und so bei tatsächlichen Bundesbehörden bin ich da irgendwie auch so ein bisschen, fällt mir nicht so viel ein. Also ich meine, das RKI hat sich jetzt auch nicht durchgehend mit rumbekleckert. Also spätestens seit sie irgendwie nicht auf die Barrikaden gegangen sind, damals, als die Regierung meinte irgendwie, Masken bringen doch sowieso nix und sind gefährlich. Ich meine, das wäre fucking Aufgabe gewesen zu sagen, Entschuldigung, Herr Gesundheitsminister, wir haben da wissenschaftlich andere Dinge, die wir wissen und die halt schon als Studien vorliegen. Und wir sollten jetzt einmal Masken aufsetzen.
Ich glaube, die sind nicht unabhängig an der Stelle, oder?
Korrekt, die sind eine Bundesbehörde.
Naja, das ist dann wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Und dann hätte ich, naja, gut, also das BSI hat irgendwie ein paar gute Stellen, die aber jetzt tatsächlich irgendwie auch zunehmend entkernt wurden, beziehungsweise halt irgendwie unter die Knechtschaft irgendwie der Abhörer gebracht worden, so.
Ey, diese Gaia-X-Nummer neulich? Das war ja so mein Moment, wo ich dachte, ey Leute, geht alle nach Hause. Da gab es dieses, wir machen jetzt eine EU-Cloud und die wird total vertrauenswürdig. Und das sah aus wie so ein üblicher Rohrkrepierer, bis es dann eine Pressemeldung von Palantir gab. Das ist so eine US-Schnüffelfirma, die Hard- und Software für Datenanalysen für Sicherheitsbehörden baut. Also so PreCock-Erkennung für Polizei und Geheimdienste. Und die haben so eine Presseerklärung veröffentlicht, so ja, wir sind ja Gründungsmitglied bei Gaia-X und alles wird gut. Und wir werden hier uns um den Datenschutz kümmern. Und dann dachte ich mir so, äh, wat? Wer hat denn das beschlossen?
Die kennen sich damit aus.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich sag ich so, okay, ja. Und das BSI, ähm, ich mein, die sind ja auch nicht unabhängig ist das Problem, ja. Die, seit die, äh, von außen den Auftrag bekommen haben, zu sagen, ob der Trojaner jetzt gut oder nicht ist, war im Grunde vorbei. Aus dem Loch kommen die nicht mehr raus, aus meiner Sicht. Also ich wüsste nicht, wie ich da jemals noch so eine Art Vertrauen aufbauen sollte, eine Behörde, die Trojaner irgendwie prüft. So geht's doch.
Na und jetzt mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz haben wir jetzt halt den quasi den finalen Todesstoß für dieses Vertrauen, weil da halt explizit drinsteht, dass die Behörden ihnen gemeldete IT-Sicherheitslücken nicht zwingend weitermelden müssen an einen Hersteller oder wie auch immer den Kram fixen kann, sondern die halt quasi entsprechend Opportunität und ob eine andere Bundesbehörde sagt, den brauchen wir jetzt gerade noch, um irgendwie die Russen zu hacken. Der Exploit geht kaputt. Und in dem Augenblick, wo man so eine Abwägung drin hat, ist für mich der Punkt, wo ich sage, okay ich finde dann Sicherheitslücken an staatliche Behörden melden, genau keine Option mehr. Also sind wir halt in so einem Bereich, wo man sagen muss, früher hätte ich gesagt, okay, zertbunt irgendwie, wenn man irgendwas Großes hat, schickt man denen zumindest noch mal eine CC-Mail, damit die Bescheid wissen so, würde ich jetzt tatsächlich einfach nicht mehr machen, sobald dieses IT-Sicherheitsgesetz durch ist, weil ich muss dann einfach sagen, ist der einzige sinnvolle Weg, ist halt einfach dann nur noch Full Disclosure.
Ja, sag ich ja, seit Jahren.
Also zwischendurch, weil man mal so der Ansicht, okay, dann kann man sich halt irgendwie im Zweifel, kann der Staat ja vielleicht irgendwie was dazu beitragen, dass irgendwie alle dazu gezwungen werden, den Scheiß zu patchen. Das ist jetzt halt nicht mehr im Interesse und auch nicht mehr gesetzlicher Auftrag des Staates, sobald dieses Gesetz durch ist. Und damit hat sich das dann halt erledigt. Und in dem Umblick fällt dann halt eben doch dieses Vertrauen flach, dass man mit denen einfach offen über Sicherheitslücken diskutieren kann.
Also, eine andere Sache, die mich beim Staat so ein bisschen immer Vertrauen gekostet hat, ist dieser Spin, der ist gerade ganz gut beobachtbar bei Brexit, weil man da eben beide Seiten sehen kann, was die der Presse an Talking Points gegeben haben, wie jetzt dieser Kompromiss aussah. Und beide Seiten haben Sieg erklärt, wo ich so dachte, so ja, okay. Wer sagt, du oder ich? Ja, so und dann denke ich mir so, okay, dann kannst du doch auch den Rest nicht glauben, den die dir erzählen. Und wie kommen wir aus diesem Loch wieder raus, ist die Frage.
Es gab ja die Leute, die halt, also insbesondere auf der libertären Seite, die dann sagten, ja, die private Unternehmertum wird uns da rausführen. Also das ist halt auch was, was mich wirklich ärgert, ist, dass bei denen, die halt eigentlich ja, sagen wir mal, was jetzt irgendwie die im Begriff der Freiheiten und Bürgerrecht und so weiter angeht, durchaus gute Punkte haben, dass die halt auf diesem Auge zu sehen, okay, auch private Unternehmen oberhalb einer bestimmten Größenordnung oder einer bestimmten Machtkonzentration sind eigentlich wie Staaten, die unterliegen genau denselben Problemen und genau denselben Machtdynamiken und sind halt überhaupt nicht gut für individuelle Freiheiten. Und ja, alles angefangen von Freedom of Speech bis irgendwie hin zu Datenschutz, sondern im Gegenteil, die sind halt einfach noch viel krasser als der Staat und verbünden sich jetzt halt mit dem Staat in ganz vielen Bereichen, beziehungsweise verschmelzen halt. Also ich meine, buchstäblich verschmelzen. Wenn wir uns jetzt angucken, bei diesen Corona-Höfen waren nicht ganz wenige dabei, wo der Staat direkt bei Unternehmen einsteigt. Und du kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen, wie viel Regulierung ein Staat machen wird, der Unternehmen, an denen er beteiligt ist, schaden wird.
Oh, da fällt mir noch eine Sache ein, die ich vorhin vergessen habe. Es gab nämlich so eine Story, dass eine Frau in ihrem Auto auf der Autobahn erschlagen wurde von einem Stück Beton, was von einer Brücke runter fiel.
Das war so eine Schallschutzwand.
Das war eine Schalldämmwand, genau. Und die zuständige Behörde hat dann angefangen zu gucken. Und da kam dann raus, das ist von zwei Firmen in Kooperation gebaut worden. Da denkst du schon, okay, kannst du vergessen. Die zeigen aufeinander. Und beide sind pleite inzwischen. Und es war eigentlich ein Test vorgesehen für dieses Stück Wand, aber das haben sie verschoben, weil irgendwie kostet ja Geld. Und die ist ja so neu. Da kann ja noch nichts sein. Und da dachte ich mir so, okay, wenn nicht mal diese Art von grundsätzlicher körperlicher Unversehrtheit eine Sache ist, bei der du dich auf den Staat verlassen kannst, was bleibt denn dann noch? Ja, der Rest über Pressefreiheit rede ich auch gerne mit dir, aber wenn die schon nicht garantieren können, dass ich nicht auf der Autobahn von runterfallenden Brückenteilen erschlagen werde, das ist erstmal wichtiger, oder? Ja, unglaublich.
Würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, wichtiger, aber zumindest gleichwertig.
Ja, aber weißt du, ich will auch, was erwarte ich denn jetzt eigentlich von Covid oder der Covid-Response, wenn die schon mal ihre Brücken nicht hinkriegen und da Leute erschlagen werden?
Ja, also das ist halt so ein Ding, was sich auf der extremen Seite dann glaube ich halt auch bei den ganzen Spinnern manifestiert, bei denen halt dieses fehlende Grundvertrauen in den Staat, sich dann halt zum Teil eben auch in so einer unmittelbaren persönlichen Betroffenheit manifestiert. Also wenn du halt irgendwie mit deiner Ice Dealer einfach pleite gegangen bist, weil irgendwie, oder deinem Kosmetik-Sendungen, weil halt irgendwie Lockdown.
Oder mit Zustand, oder andere Einzelhandel. Wir haben gerade eine riesige Pleitewelle, die durchs Land rollt. Da lesen wir eigentlich viel zu wenig von. Ich frage mich auch, warum.
Na, weil die noch bis zum Frühjahr delayed ist. Also weil es gibt halt irgendwie Mietzuschüsse und so weiter. Und es gibt jetzt halt irgendwie die Höfen, die jetzt noch irgendwie im Dezember laufen sollen. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Also ich vermute mal, dass viele auch mit ihren Vermietern ausgehandelt haben, dass sie die Miete nachzahlen, wenn halt irgendwie die Höfen eintreffen. Nur wenn halt irgendwie die Ausseilung dieser Höfen genauso läuft wie bisher, nämlich dass du halt als normaler, als kleines mittelständisches Unternehmen halt irgendwie kaum in der Lage bist, halt irgendwie diese Anforderungen zu erfüllen, weil die dann halt sagen, du musst die letzten drei Jahre profitabel gewesen sein oder so was. So Regeln gab es ja dann. Also dass du halt irgendwie, wenn du halt in den letzten drei Jahren mal ein nicht profitables Jahr hattest, dann kriegst du halt nicht, darfst du halt nicht. Also es sind unterschiedlichste Hilfsprogramme mit unterschiedlichen Regeln. Und du brauchst da mittlerweile so Experten und Experten-Systeme für, um halt irgendwie diese Regeln irgendwie, also diese Sachen korrekt zu beantragen. Und nach außen ist dann wieder genau das, was du gesagt hast mit der Propaganda. Aber wir haben noch 25 Milliarden halt irgendwie.
Wir haben Maßnahmen ergriffen.
Genau. Also am geilsten finde ich dann immer ja, wir haben 25 Milliarden Hilfen irgendwie bereitgestellt. Und dann so dreimal später, irgendwie wurden nur 21 Milliarden davon abgerufen. Wir verstehen das ja auch nicht so.
Und ja, na, also was mich ja sofort geärgert hat an diesen Hilfen war, dass sie gesagt haben, das kannst du nicht für dein Essen ausgeben. Ja, wenn du sagen wir mal ein darbender Künstler bist, nur für deine Miete darfst du denn, das heißt Rent Seeking, also die Leute, die nicht arbeiten für ihr Einkommen, die werden staatlich garantiert am Leben gehalten. Aber die Leute, die arbeiten wollen, aber es wegen dem Staat grad nicht nicht können, die werden pleite gegenlassen. Aber ich dachte so, das ist doch genau falsch rum.
Für mich stellt sich halt die Frage, was für Auswirkungen hat es dann auf so den strategischen Blick auf die Welt? Also wenn man halt jetzt sieht, so die Situation ist nur in sehr wenigen Ländern irgendwie besser. Also im Sinne von, da haben die Staaten halt nicht versagt, da haben sie halt irgendwie sinnvolle Maßnahmen ergriffen und waren halt hinreichend schnell unterwegs, um halt irgendwie diesen Corona-Kram halt irgendwie halbwegs in den Griff zu bekommen. Und trotzdem hast du dann halt irgendwie an vielen Stellen halt immer so die Situation, du hast halt jetzt ein relativ starres, schon zum Teil gecaptchertes Regelwerk, was du eigentlich mal abreißen und neu bauen müsstest. Bloß die Komplexität ist halt so groß, dass du mit extrem hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit wieder in einem Regelwerk landest, wo du halt noch mehr Regulatory Capture hast. Also nur halt auf einer größeren Ebene und irgendwie mit subtilen Seiteneffekten, die du halt nicht verstehst als Staat, weil dir halt einfach anzwischen wahrscheinlich die intellektuelle Kapazität dazu abhanden gekommen ist.
Also wollen wir hier mal...
Nee, wer denn? Ich meine, wer geht denn dahin? Also ich meine, im Sinne von intellektuelle Bandbreite, ich sage jetzt nicht, dass die Leute dumm sind, sondern nur im Sinne von du brauchst halt für komplexes Thema philisch schlaue Leute, die willens und hart zu arbeiten. So und das ist halt jetzt nicht so meine Vorstellung von, was jetzt halt irgendwie... Also wenn man sich jetzt halt irgendwie dieses BaFin-Nummer anguckt, ganz ehrlich.
Du, also ehrlich gesagt, Wirecard war bei mir sozusagen die Kür. Davor hat BaFin die Fintechs in den Markt gelassen, die der Schufa ermöglichen, diesen Deal mit Telefonika zu machen, der jetzt so ein bisschen in der Presse war, den sie dann gecancelt haben, als der Aufschrei zu groß war. Aber im Wesentlichen hat die Finanzneuregulierung ermöglicht, dass irgendwelche Gammel-Startups als Geschäftsmodell den Leuten in die Konten gucken können. Und da brauchst du keine schlauen Leute, um zu erkennen, dass das eine schlechte Idee ist, aus meiner Sicht. Das ist auch keine Frage der Komplexität, sondern es ist eine selbst zugefügte Wunde, dieses Fass überhaupt erst aufzumachen. Und da dachte ich schon, okay, also die werden mich nicht beschützen. Also egal, was das Problem ist, wenn die das schon nicht sehen, dass das eine schlechte Idee ist, dann ist auch egal, ob die jetzt bei Wirecard hingeguckt haben oder nicht. So und diese Art von Versagen, wo ich, also ich habe, bin ich der Letzte, der kein Verständnis dafür hat, dass Leute mit Komplexität nicht klarkommen. Das ist das Grundproblem in der Softwareentwicklung. Das ist mein tägliches Brot. Aber es gibt halt viele Probleme. Das ist keine Komplexitätsfrage, ob du da was tust oder nicht. Ich hab den Eindruck, das ist eher so Yes-Minister-Style-Komplexität. Dass du so tust, als sei es komplexer, als es tatsächlich ist, damit die Leute keine doofen Fragen stellen. Und das finde ich einen viel größeren Verrat, als wenn die Leute an ihrer eigenen Komplexität zugrunde gehen. Wenn das nun eine Scheinkomplexität ist.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es dann auch wieder so ein Ding von Erwartungsmanagement. In dem Umblick, wo niemand mehr erwartet, dass sich ein Staat kompetent verhält, nimmt auch niemand mehr an, dass irgendwie offensichtlicher Unsinn, den sie irgendwie tun oder beschließen, jetzt halt böse Absicht ist. Sondern alle gehen erst mal davon aus, dass sie sowieso nur wieder verkacken.
Naja, aber das ist doch wie so eine Sepsis. Wenn du es nicht im Anlass schon verhinderst, kommst du da nicht wieder raus.
Ja, das ist korrekt. Naja, und jetzt haben wir dann halt irgendwie auch noch wieder den nächsten Push, dass sie halt irgendwie noch stärker und noch tiefer ins Internet rein regulieren wollen.
Naja, und wir haben ja tatsächlich die Fragen zwischen Staaten, über die wir eigentlich reden wollten, bevor ich hier links abgebogen bin ins Gebüsch. Genau, erzähl doch mal so ein bisschen, was du da beobachtet hast.
Na, was zwischen den Staaten ja gerade passiert, ist halt so eine Renaissance des Nationalstaats. Also das ist halt also die auch getrieben von dem, der Suche nach einfachen Antworten bei ihren eigenen Bevölkerungen. Also wo halt irgendwie die Bevölkerung sagt, wir wollen jetzt hier nicht mehr so viel komplexe Scheiße, sondern wir wollen, dass irgendwie möglichst irgendwie, ja, wir gegen die Antworten halt irgendwie dabei rauskommen. Also was ja irgendwie immer das ist, was am besten funktioniert, wenn man halt irgendwie sagen kann, so schuld sind die da drüben, irgendwie sie hier Brexit. Und wir müssen uns irgendwie auf unsere national Identität besinnen. Und die spülen natürlich entsprechende Politiker nach oben. So, weil die Globalisierung ist halt für eine ganze Menge Leute halt einfach viel zu überfordert. Also abgesehen von den objektiv schädlichen Dingen ist Globalisierung ja durchaus auch was, was irgendwie viele Vorteile hat. Nur, dass sie halt irgendwie dazu führt, dass halt eine globale Arbeitsteilung halt irgendwie nicht dazu führt, dass der Wohlstand lokal gleich verteilt ist, sondern das halt irgendwie ist im Wesentlichen dazu führt, dass zwar mehr Leute aus der Armut rauskommen, aber halt irgendwie das, was früher die Mittelschicht war, halt irgendwie zunehmend eher so untere Mittelschicht, wenn nicht noch drunter wird. Und dieses Muster von Fortschritt führt zwar dazu, dass wir irgendwie mehr Diagonale auf unseren Fernsehern bekommen und irgendwie billigere Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, aber führt halt jetzt nicht dazu, dass wir ein objektiv reicheres Leben haben, sondern halt in der Regel ist für die meisten Leute mehr Arbeit, weniger Freizeit und mehr Stress. So müssen sie sich permanent auf neue Dinge einstellen, müssen halt irgendwie neue Sachen lernen, stehen plötzlich in Konkurrenz mit Leuten auf der anderen Seite des Planeten. Und diese ganze Dynamik zusammen mit Automatisierung und irgendwie künstliche Diligenz und so weiter, was jetzt da kommt, also in Anführungszeichen, also Maschinen-Learning-Systemen und immer stärkere Integration von irgendwie allem mit allem, führt halt dazu, dass die Leute irgendwie einfacher antworten wollen. Und die einfachste Antwort ist halt irgendwie, das soll so sein wie früher, ne? So, früher, wie abzeitig...
Das finde ich faszinierend, weil ich habe nämlich die Vermutung gehabt, dass wir es mit einem neu auflebenden Imperialismus zu tun haben. Ja, also ich beziehe mich jetzt auf das chinesische Meer, wo sich die Anrainerländer jetzt darum kloppen, wer da die irgendwelche Inselgruppen gehören, wo im Grunde völlig wurscht ist, wem die gehören, aber es geht halt um so Machtsphären und darum mal wieder gegen anderes Land irgendwie einen Vorteil erhoben zu haben. Und gut, Deutschland macht auch mit, aber jetzt nicht im Sinne von wir marschieren irgendwo ein, sondern wir ziehen Leute in die EU rein oder verhindern halt, dass sie rauskommen oder verhandeln mit ihnen, dass es ihnen möglichst scheiße geht, wenn sie rausgehen. So das habe ich zumindest, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das eine komplette These ist, aber mein Eindruck war, das kann man auch als neuen Imperialismus sehen. Und ich dachte mir, das passt eigentlich auch in eine krisengebeutelte Zeit. Das ist immer eine gute Antwort, wenn es innenpolitisch scheiße läuft, dass man irgendwie einen externen Feind aufbaut und sich an dem abarbeitet.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Vorstell nicht komplementärer. Also wenn du jetzt davon ausgehst, dass Staaten unterschiedliche Entwicklungsstadien unterschiedliche präferierte Machtmittel haben, auch ausgehend von ihrer geostrategischen Situation, sehen wir trotzdem genau diesen Trend. Also dass halt irgendwie dieses sich Vergewissern der eigenen Nationalstaatlichkeit dazu führt, dass alles, was daran schlecht ist, eben auch mit hochkommt. Also dass halt irgendwie, wir müssen uns noch einen schönen Strand dazu erobern, beziehungsweise das Meer da vorne ist unseres, da durften irgendwie die anderen nicht durchfahren oder was auch immer. Wir wollen nicht irgendwie weiter uns von der EU vorschreiben lassen, wie krumm so eine Banane ist. Das sind halt alles so Sachen, die natürlich auch dadurch getrieben sind, dass die Vorteile von globaler Integration und Regulierung, die immer größere Wirtschaftsblöcke betreffen, also sprich jetzt insbesondere die EU, die gehen natürlich auch vergessen. Das ist halt so was wie europäische Standardisierung, dass wir überall in Europa dieselbe Steckdose haben, außer in Großbritannien. Irgendwie habe ich mich daran gewöhnt, dass ich innerhalb von Europa eigentlich keinen Steckdosenadapter mehr mitnehmen muss. Oder dass du eigentlich davon ausgehen kannst, dass egal, wo du in der EU in den Supermarkt gehst, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du da irgendwas kaufst, was dir jetzt wirklich aktiv schadet, halt relativ gering ist, weil bestimmte Regeln und Regularien sind halt überall da. Aber diese Selbstverstetigung von solchen Bürokratien, die dann dazu führt, dass sie sagen, jetzt haben wir diese schöne Bürokratie und wir sind total super daran, Regeln zu entwickeln und wir haben auch noch irgendwie Freunde in den Unternehmen, die eigentlich noch gerne mehr Regeln haben wollen, weil sie damit Konkurrenten benachteiligen können, führt dann dazu, dass sie halt nicht aufhören.
Das war ja auch zentraler Streitpunkt bei den Brexit-Verhandlungen. Das fand ich sehr spannend. Also es ging im Wesentlichen um die Fischereirechte der Franzosen vor der britischen Küste. Das war der eine wirklich umkämpfte Punkt. Und der andere war, was ist denn jetzt, wenn sagen wir mal die EU neue Regularien macht für irgendwie, was weiß ich, eine Substanz gilt jetzt als gefährlich. Ja, und darf nicht mehr in Produkten drin sein. Und UK macht aber noch Produkte damit. Dürfen die das dann trotzdem bei uns einführen oder darf der Zoll das beschlagnahmen? Das war der andere Punkt. Das heißt, man darf das gar nicht unterschätzen, was das für ein wichtiger Aspekt ist im Handel heutzutage. Auch mit den Chinesen, ja. Da haben wir ja auch irgendwelche Regulierungen einfach gemacht. Und die schummeln sich da jetzt bei Amazon drum rum, mit irgendwelchen Geräten ohne CESiegel und so ein Scheiß. Das sind ja...
Die CESiegel drucken sie inzwischen alle drauf, weil CES eine Selbsterkleidung ist.
Ist eine Selbsterkleidung, genau. Aber dass es überhaupt dieses Problem gab, das ist ja eine der Regulierungen, die wir hier haben. Das CESiegel soll ja unter anderem dir versichern, wenn du einen Toaster kaufst, dass der nicht explodiert, wenn du ihn anschließt. Das ist eigentlich eine der Erfolgsgeschichten der EU, aber das merkst du halt nicht mehr, wenn du dich daran gewöhnt hast. Und ich glaube, das ist mit den offenen Grenzen genauso. Das ist mir erst aufgefallen, was das für ein Einschnitt wäre, als es plötzlich real war.
Aber mein Punkt war ja, dass statt zu sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt halt eine Welt, die auch dank Regulierung irgendwie innerhalb der EU relativ komfortabel ist, hört es ja nicht auf. Sondern was wir jetzt halt haben, ist halt dieser Moment, wo alle sich denken, okay, jetzt ist aber eigentlich, also eigentlich ist doch okay so. Also es ist halt so wie, klar, wir können jetzt noch irgendeinen Stoff verbieten, der halt irgendwie, wo wir jetzt neue MS-Geräte gebaut haben und können den jetzt nochmal in irgendwie 5 Pikogramm pro Megatonne statt irgendwie 10 Mikrogramm pro Megatonne nachweisen. Soweit gibt es natürlich auch immer. Da kann man auch ganz super noch ein Skandal ausmachen. Und das ist nämlich, glaube ich, auch so ein Punkt, der dazu beiträgt, dass es halt immer weitergeht, dass immer mehr Sachen irgendwie reguliert werden sollen. Journalisten. Weil, wenn du dir so einen Journalisten anguckst, der sucht ja eigentlich immer nach irgendeinem Skandal. Irgendetwas, was er beklagen kann, was er enthüllen kann, was er anprangern kann. Also wie zum Beispiel halt diese deutsche Umwelthöfe. Das ist ja irgendwie die besten PR-Anprangerer überhaupt. Und ob sie irgendwas anprangern, was irgendwie tatsächlich ein Problem ist, oder halt irgendwie was anprangern, was halt Bullshit ist, oder wo sie die freundlich formuliert, die die Auswirkungen drastisch übertreiben, ist denen halt eigentlich egal, solange sie Schlagzeilen produzieren, die dazu führen, dass sie ihre Journalisten vorne Schlagzeilen haben und ansonsten sie halt Spenden bekommen, damit sie irgendwie weitermachen können. Und daraus folgt halt, dass je mehr strenge Regulierungen und Grenzwerte es gibt, jedes Mal, wenn die halt irgendwie strenger werden und irgendwie mehr reguliert wird, gibt es halt irgendwie eine Flut von Geschichten, von Sachen, die jetzt plötzlich ein Skandal sind, die exakt genauso sind wie vorgestern. Es hat tatsächlich nichts geändert. So ist es halt genauso geblieben, die Welt ist exakt so wie vorher. Da hat sich materiell genau gar nichts geändert, aber plötzlich ist es ein Skandal.
Aber wir wissen jetzt mehr.
Na ja, und die Regeln haben sich geändert. Genau. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, was ich halt immer mehr sehe, wo ich sagen muss, okay, die psychologischen Folgen davon, dass die Leute dann irgendwann sagen, also gerade warum haben wir so viele Selbstständige und Kleinunternehmer unter den Corona-Spinnern? Weil die genau in diesen Punkt gelaufen sind, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, das hat halt irgendwie alles eigentlich ganz okay funktioniert und plötzlich machen wir genau das selbe, was wir gestern gemacht haben und plötzlich ist es illegal. Das ist gut ein Grund in diesem Fall, weil klar war, dass bestimmte Einschränkungen notwendig sind, wobei man darüber diskutieren kann, ob jetzt alle diese Einschränkungen notwendig und zielführend waren. Aber daraus resultiert dann eben auch dieses Wegbrechen des Grundvertrauens, dass der Staat schon Dinge tun wird, die okay sind. Und ich glaube, das ist halt so ein Problem, was sich in diesem Brexit halt auch in gewisser Art und Weise manifestiert hat. Nämlich genau dieses, warum muss das jetzt halt einfach immer noch weitergehen? Warum können wir nicht mal Bremsen einbauen, die sagen, jede Regel kostet. Für jede neue Regel muss es eine sinnvolle Begründung geben, dass das, was wir da tun, wirklich einen signifikanten Benefit und Mehrwert gibt. Also zum Beispiel dieser Feinstaubkram. Also wir haben jetzt irgendwie diese Feinstaubregeln und die gelten halt nur für Autos.
Ja, und nicht für die Kamine.
Und nicht für irgendwie die Spaß- und Spielholzkamine in der Stadt, die halt Leute haben, weil sie es halt schön finden. Und die müssen zwar eigentlich theoretisch auch einmal mehr vom Schornsteinfeger abgenommen werden, bloß dass da dann ein Schornsteinfeger sagt, ja diesen Kamin müssen wir leider stilllegen, weil er zu viel Feinstaub produziert, ist mir irgendwie bisher noch nicht untergekommen. So und daraus, aber da entsteht halt irgendwie so ein Problemfeld von Dinge, die sinnvoll und richtig sind, weil sie halt das Leben besser machen. Damit sind wir eigentlich im Wesentlichen durch. Wir müssen uns jetzt den harten Themen zufinden. Wir müssen uns jetzt den Themen...
Da werd ich aber vorsichtig...
Na Moment, ich meine wir müssen uns jetzt mal sagen, was macht denn irgendwie das Leben von Leuten besser? Dann müssten wir uns halt mit sowas beschäftigen, wie irgendwie Mindestanzahl von Beschäftigten in der Pflege. Dann müssten wir uns halt beschäftigen, ok, wieso können eigentlich Altenheime so betrieben werden und Pflegeheime so betrieben werden, wie sie momentan betrieben werden? Was ist eigentlich mit diesen ganzen Krankenhäusern? Warum müssen die eigentlich profitabel sein? Wieso haben wir immer noch die Situation, dass es in vielen Bereichen eigentlich vollständig unzureichende staatliche Regeln gibt, wie zum Beispiel halt in der Fleischverarbeitung. Also da müssten wir halt eigentlich jetzt mal ran. Und stattdessen beschäftigen wir uns damit, ob wir jetzt irgendwie einen Picogramm irgendwie Acrylamid in irgendeiner Schokolade gefunden haben. Sowas. Und deshalb glaube ich, so die, ich sag mal, die, die zu lösen, die einfach zu lösen Probleme sind jetzt halt im Wesentlichen alle. Und die harten Probleme würden die Systemfrage stellen, beziehungsweise müsste man da halt dann mal irgendwie ein bisschen krasser rangehen. Also beschäftigen wir uns jetzt halt irgendwie mit Problemen und versuchen, die zu regulieren und noch irgendwie schwieriger zu machen. Die halt entweder Unternehmen, also großen Unternehmen gegen kleine Unternehmen, nutzen. Oder halt irgendwie im Wesentlichen halt irgendwie aufregende Ablenkungen sind.
Da würde ich gerne zurückcyceln zu, wo wir vorhin waren. Denn ich glaube, das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass die Politik gern so tun möchte, als würde sie irgendwas regulieren, aber es dann halt nicht tut, sondern nur so ein PR-Move macht. Also ich sag mal jetzt zum Beispiel als Beispiel, die Tageldöner auf den Spargelfeldern, die dieses Jahr wegen Covid ausgefallen sind, war ja so ein Ding, was wir seit Jahrzehnten dulden, dass da im Grunde Sklaverei betrieben wird. Dass unsere Arbeitsvorschriften einfach weitgehend ignoriert werden. Und wenn der Staat gesagt hat, wir müssen jetzt mal was geschehen, dann war die Antwort, ja, aber dann wird das zu teuer, dann lohnt sich das nicht mehr. Als wenn das ein Argument wäre. Entweder wir sagen, irgendwie bei uns gibt es Menschenrechte oder nicht. Also aus meiner Sicht ist das nicht eine Sache, die noch nachreguliert werden muss, sondern wir haben eigentlich die Regularien schon. Wir wenden so nicht überall an. Oder Mindestlohn ist am Ende gescheitert an den Zeitungsauslieferern. Das ist doch auch so ein Ding. Warum haben wir das eigentlich geduldet, dass Zeitungsauslieferer kein ordentliches Gehalt kriegen?
Weil die Verlage sich darüber beschwert haben und die Verlage sind halt bis zum nächsten Wahlkampf noch wichtig.
Genau, so sieht es aus. Aber aus meiner Sicht ist es nicht so, dass wir zu wenig Regularien haben, sondern die richtigen Regularien haben wir eigentlich schon. Die werden ja nicht umgesetzt. Zum Beispiel sind sich seit vielen Jahren alle einig, dass wir mehr Fahrradwege brauchen. Ja, und jetzt guckt ihr die Umsetzung halt so. Und es gibt einige Sachen, die kriegst du auch mit Regularien nicht weg. Aber ich glaube, man kann hier tatsächlich Sachen lernen aus der Softwareentwicklung. Denn in der Softwareentwicklung gibt es tatsächlich den Ansatz, gelegentlich wird ja auch ausprobiert, das einfach wegzuschmeißen und neu zu machen. Wenn du merkst, das ist zu komplex. Wir haben hier zu viele Ausnahmen und Ausnahmen von Ausnahmen. Das ist alles nicht mehr wartbar. Das ist ja das Equalent zu dem, was wir gerade in der Politik erleben. Dass du sagst, okay, wir schmeißen es jetzt weg und machen es neu. Und was dabei praktisch sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche rauskommt, ist, dass das zweite System noch viel komplexer und größer und beschissener wird. Weil sich nämlich herausstellt, dass jeder Einzelne von diesen Ausnahmen einen Grund hatte, warum sie da war. Und das hat nicht jemand was übersehen oder da hat jemand bei der Umsetzung geschlammt, sondern es gibt für jeden einzelnen Verkacker einen guten Grund. Das sind alle Theorien, die davon ausgehen, dass ein Politiker inkompetent war, sind aus meiner Sicht falsch. Sondern die Regularien sind nicht scheiße, weil jemand inkompetent war, sondern weil das mit Absicht da so hingeschrieben wurde. Es gab einfach dann vielleicht hinter dem Vorhang irgendeinen Mechanismus, den du nicht kennst.
Es gibt halt Ausnahmen, Andy Scheuer zum Beispiel.
Ja gut, es gibt Ausnahmen. Haha, immer auf die Arme zieh jetzt ruf. Ey, na gut. Ja, es gibt Ausnahmen. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es so, dass sich beim Neustart von einem System praktisch immer rausstellt, dass die Komplexität einfach einen Grund hatte. Und wenn du das neu machst, läufst du in genau dieselben Situationen wieder rein und kommst mit genauso vielen Ausnahmen raus. Das heißt, wichtiger als neu machen ist, zu verstehen, warum das so ist. Und da sehe ich eigentlich ein großes Problem, dass man einfach viel zu viel so Schall und Rauch und Geblende und PR-Ablenkungsscheiße hat, sodass eine rationale Betrachtung der Situation einfach auch gar nicht mehr möglich ist. Also ich meinte vorhin mit Imperialismus übrigens, also die Chinesen haben gerade so ein Programm, was tatsächlich militär, wo es darum geht, so Flugzeugträger auf Land zu bauen, das gerne umschrieben, die haben so ein kleines Inselchen, was sie vielleicht sogar noch künstlich aufgeschüttet haben, und montieren da halt Artillerie und eine kleine Start- und Landebahn und so drauf. Das heißt, wir reden hier tatsächlich von Militär, nicht nur von Wirtschaftsgeschichten. Daher war mein Eindruck, dass man vielleicht auch einen Teil Imperialismus wieder hat. Was, glaube ich, eine Auswirkung davon ist, was du vorhin meintest, dass wir jetzt eine Stärkung der Nationalsachen haben. Was ich, glaube ich, auch für ein natürliches Resultat von Krisensituationen ist, dass man sagt, okay, das ist alles scheiße, wir müssen zumindest gucken, dass es nicht schlimmer wird. Indem wir jetzt sagen, okay, zumindest bei uns, dann fängst du an, dich zu beschränken und sagst, okay, also vielleicht den Rest der EU können wir vielleicht nicht retten, aber wir machen jetzt bei dir Grenzen zu. Das ist ja genau so was. Insofern sind die Mechanismen, glaube ich, dieselben. Aber es kommen halt Sachen raus, die wir eigentlich alle nicht haben wollten, dass irgendwie jemand einen Krieg im chinesischen Meer... Also ganz krude Geschichten auch. Die Chinesen bauen halt diese Inseln, die Amerikaner schicken dann so einen Flugzeugträgerverband vorbei und belästigen damit irgendwie einen russischen Marine-Stützpunkt. Und dann denkst du so, was soll denn das? Habt ihr alle irgendwie nichts zu tun? Ja, so was? Was glaubt ihr denn, was man hier gewinnen kann? Das ist so wie irgendwie verunsicherte Teenager auf einem Schulhof, die sich dann gegenseitig irgendwie schubsen. Weil es geht gar nicht darum, irgendwie tatsächlich Kraft zu zeigen, sondern sich selbst zu überzeugen, dass man noch Kraft hat, ist mein Eindruck. Wenn du schon an dem eigentlichen Problem nichts gelöst kriegst, dann verprügelst du halt irgendeinen armen Passanten und denkst ja, ich bin doch jemand so. Ich glaube, das ist so der Hintergedanke.
Na gut, wobei halt, sagen wir mal so, bei den geostrategischen Überlegungen Richtung China, muss man schon...
Das geht auch echt um Geld, das will ich nicht abredestellen.
Ja, und um, sagen wir mal, langfristige strategische Abwägungen. Also das ist halt schon so, dass das so ein Bereich ist, wo man zumindest den beteiligten Staaten nicht vorwerfen kann, dass sie sich nicht darüber Gedanken machen, wie die Welt in 10 oder 20 Jahren aussieht. Insbesondere nicht den Chinesen. Also die denken ja schon in längeren Zyklen. Und was wir da halt sehen, ist halt eine verabschiedung von dieser internationalen Konsensordnung, die halt irgendwie so in den 90ern und Anfang der 2000er so halbwegs funktioniert hat, hin zu so einem, okay, was die Amis sich rausnehmen, können wir uns auch rausnehmen, weil offensichtlich ist es ja ganz normal. Na, es ist halt so, ja, irgendwie, also siehst du ja auch im Bereich von, ja, Cyberwar, hast du halt irgendwie eigentlich genau dasselbe Spiel, so alle nehmen sich halt das raus, was die Amis halt auch gemacht haben, weil sie halt haben so, ja, warum sollten die jetzt special sein? Und was wir da halt beobachten, ist halt, dass niemand eigentlich mehr diese Idee des amerikanischen Exceptionalismus, also dass die Amis halt irgendwie besser, was besseres sind, akzeptiert. Die sind jetzt halt einfach nur noch das Land, was halt zufällig mehr Flugzeugträger und Automoboter als alle anderen hat. So, aber nicht mehr, es wurde halt nicht mehr irgendwie anerkannt, dass die halt irgendwie sich aus irgendeinem anderen Grund mehr rausnehmen können als andere, sondern nur noch im Rahmen von der Macht, die sie tatsächlich auf die Straßen bringen können. So und wenn man sich da so anguckt, was die Chinesen und die Russen da jetzt gerade bauen, halt irgendwie mit irgendwie Hyperschall-Raketen und interne Kontinentalraketen, die so manövrierfähig sind, dass man damit halt irgendwie Flugzeugträger platt machen kann und so. Das sind halt schon Entwicklungen, die halt relativ klar darauf hinweisen, dass diese Diskussion, die da so gerade aus den Army-Thinktanks kommt, von wegen so, ok, der nächste Krieg findet im Pazifik statt, da ist halt schon durchaus was dran. Also ist jetzt nicht komplett an den Haaren herbeigezogen und die strategische Schwenken der Amerikaner Richtung Pazifik ist halt einfach auch nicht mehr zu leugnen. Die wissen halt ganz genau, wo ihr Feind demnächst sein wird. Und die Chinesen sehen das ja genauso. Und wenn sich zwei Seiten einig sind, dass jeweils die andere der zukünftige Feind sein wird, dann gibt es halt eben auch nicht mehr so viel, was es halt irgendwie aufhalten kann, wenn man sich von so einer halbwegs konsensualen Weltaufgabe verabschiedet hat.
Also ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass die Amerikaner zusehends so Schwäche zeigen. Gerade unter Trump, der hat halt so ein bisschen den Eindruck auch erweckt, naja, der bellt, aber beißt nicht. Also vielleicht irgendwie ein paar Wirtschaftssanktionen, aber die muss er dann auch zurücknehmen, weil es ihm mehr wehtut als den Chinesen. Ich glaube, das hat seinen Teil auch dazu beigetragen. Urbano hat ja auch versucht, Kriege umzuschwenken auf Drone Strikes, anstatt von tatsächlich irgendwie, wo irgendein Soldat tatsächlich gefährdet ist. Und das merken natürlich die anderen Player. Und wenn China dann sagt, hör mal, das ist hier vor unserer Haustür, da geht unsere gesamte Exportwirtschaft durch, das sollten wir kontrollieren, dann ist da ja auch was dran. Wieso sollten eigentlich die Amis für diese Shipping-Lane verantwortlich sein, die am anderen Ende des Planeten ist?
Ja, weil sie die meisten Schiffe haben momentan noch, also bis 2025 ungefähr. Die Amerikaner? Ja, die US Navy ist tatsächlich...
Ach so, Kriegsschiffe meint sie jetzt nicht, die meint jetzt vom Handelsvolumen her.
Ach so, vom Handelsvolumen her, gut, da würde Panama gewinnen. Ja, gut, aber das ist ja nun Steueroptimierung. Nee, aber tatsächlich ist halt dieser Hegemonialanspruch der Amerikaner sortiert halt eben auch daraus, dass sie den halt Kraft ihrer Wassersuppe halt irgendwie nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg halt hatten. So und jetzt sagen die Chinesen so, naja, wir haben da halt eine klare Timeline. 2025 wollen wir halt genauso viele Schiffe haben wie die Amis und ungefähr denselben Klassen, außer dass wir halt nicht so viele Flugzeugträger bauen wollen, sondern halt mehr U-Boote und irgendwie kleinere Schiffe, weil irgendwie Flugzeugträger halt einfach nur schwimmende Zielscheiben sind. Aber die Frage, was folgt daraus für die europäischen Staaten, sieht halt leider auch nicht so gut aus. Weil letzten Endes ist die absehbare rationale Strategie, also wenn man jetzt irgendwie Menschenrechts- und Moralkategorien und Ethikkategorien außer Acht lässt, ist halt für Europa halt so ein Festungseuropa-Ding. Also wir kapseln uns ab, wir haben unsere eigenen Regulierungen und wir versuchen halt irgendwie unsere guten Regeln zu exportieren. Also halt irgendwie Steckdosen und Lebensmittelsicherheit und so. Und im Inneren versuchen wir halt irgendwie mit mehr Überwachung, Internetzensur, dem allmöglichen Begründungen, um irgendwie verschlüsselte Kommunikation lesen zu können und so weiter. Halt irgendwie den, ja, sagen wir so eine europäische Bindenhegemonie halt irgendwie herzustellen. So und dazu gehört natürlich dann halt eben auch der Aufbau von Infrastruktur. Dies halt im Zweifel ermöglicht halt irgendwie großen Internetunternehmen halt irgendwie das Leben schwer zu machen. So aus gutem Grund ganz oft. Na also, wenn wir uns GDP ansehen, so bei aller Kritik darin hat es zumindest dazu geführt, dass sich mal ein bisschen was zum Positiven verändert hat. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass es durchgehend positiv ist, aber es hat zumindest dazu geführt, dass halt irgendwie bestimmte Auswüchse jetzt irgendwie wie Facebook und so weiter nicht mehr so ohne weiteres operieren können. Und ich glaube, der Versuch, der gerade läuft gerade jetzt insbesondere unter Osla von der Leyen, zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt noch viel, viel mehr regulieren und unter dem Deckmantel des Incheckhaltens der Multicorps und der MegaCorps werden wir da halt irgendwie auch noch unsere Überwachungsgesetze durchdrücken. Das wird heute sein, was uns halt die nächsten Jahre halt irgendwie busy hält.
Naja, also ich weiß nicht, ich sehe es ja nicht so, dass wir nur die Möglichkeit mit der Festung haben. Auch wenn ich dir da inhaltlich schon recht geben will, aber das war ja nicht in Stein gemeißelt. Wir hätten ja irgendwie, sagen wir mal, die Afrikaner ordentlich behandeln können, wie Handelspartner auf Augenhöhe. Stattdessen exportieren wir da unseren Müll hin und nehmen ihnen ihre Bodenschätze ab und bezahlen irgendwie nichts und freuen uns, wenn da ein Diktator regiert, weil der ein stabilerer Handelspartner ist, weil der die Kohle für seine Waffen braucht. So und wenn das das Existierende der Status Quo ist, dann darf man sich nicht wundern, dass die Chinesen da irgendwie in großem Stil einen Durchmarsch machen, wenn sie einfach hingehen und sagen, hör mal, ihr braucht Straßen, wir bauen euch mal ein paar Straßen. Ja und dann plötzlich völlig überraschend sind die ganzen afrikanischen Staaten mit den Chinesen befreundet und in Europa bewundern sich alle. Ja, und ihr braucht ein Kraftwerk, hier ist ein Kraftwerk. Ja, alles was wir wollen, ist, dass wir auf eurem Hafen einlaufen können. So welches Land sagt denn dazu nein? Und Europa hat das halt verkackt und zwar nach Strich und Faden aus meiner Sicht. Das ist überhaupt nicht kein Selbstläufer gewesen, dass wir jetzt hier nur noch Festungen machen können, sondern das haben wir verkackt. Ja und eine andere Strategie neben der Festung wäre, dass man zumindest jetzt versucht, für die Chinesen ein attraktiverer Markt zu sein als die USA. Die Frage ist, ob wir das machen können, solange wir hier auf Regularien setzen. Ob die Amerikaner nicht einfach einen Vorteil haben, dadurch, dass sie irgendwie im Zweifelsfall drauf scheißen, ob da Quacksilber drin ist oder nicht.
Bei den Amis ist ja die Sache noch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil halt viele davon ja Bundesländerregulierungen sind und da ist ja quasi Kalifornien mehr so auf Augenhöhe mit Europa, also teilweise gar noch darüber hinausgehend, was halt halt um die Regularien angeht. Was aber eben auch dazu führt, dass innerhalb der USA dann halt auch einfach Abwanderung stattfindet. Also jetzt bestimmte Regeln, die jetzt halt in Kalifornien, also teilweise auch noch bis weiter runter, also ich hatte das jetzt irgendwie neulich zufällig, was du halt alles in San Francisco nicht tun darfst. Und da denkst du dir halt auch so, okay, da ist also so zwischen dem, was die da so haben und dem, was wir in Europa so haben, so Land of the Free ist dann halt doch eher hier so, ne? Also so...
Ja.
Also...
Naja, also es ist ja wirklich gerade so, dass Tech-Companies aus Silicon Valley abziehen und nicht nur aus Steuergründen, sondern auch aus Regulariumsvermeidung. Die Kalifornier sind da halt relativ krass, ja. Und das ist aber auch größtenteils Aktivismus, denn den Leuten geht's ja nicht besser darunter, sondern die haben ja diese Rolling Blackouts gehabt, wenn ich daran mal erinnern darf, weil die Stromregulierung verkackt hat. Also, viel Regulierung heißt halt nicht, dass es besser wird, sondern es muss gute Regulierung sein.
Naja, so minimal wie möglich halt, ne? Das ist halt so, aber halt irgendwie so viel wie nötig.
Wir hatten ja die Chance, das jetzt alles richtig zu machen mit dem Internet. Das Internet war ja ein unregulierter wilder Westen. Auf der anderen Seite war es ein Community-Raum, den man selbst hätte irgendwie erfüllen können, mit schönen Inhalten und das hätte ein Instrument der Erleuchtung sein können. Und jetzt ist es eher so ein Spielball der Regulierungswut einzelner Länder.
Naja, ich glaube.
Haben wir das verkackt oder haben die das verkackt?
Es gibt so zwei Momente in der Geschichte des Internets oder des Netzes. Die ich da so als Knackpunkte benennen würde, um also nach dem Motto, wenn ich jetzt eine Zeitmaschine hätte und ich könnte jetzt irgendwie ins Jahr von 1993 zurückreisen, was würde ich dann versuchen, anders zu machen?
Das WWW verhindern, vorher war alles gut.
Nee, das Problem war, dass es nicht gelungen ist, vor dem Platzen der Start-up-Bugle um das Jahr 2000 rum, ein System zu schaffen, wo Micro-Payments möglich waren. Und zwar, also technisch wäre das schon gegangen, das wäre tatsächlich möglich gewesen. Und es hätte dazu geführt, dass wir ein vollständig anderes Internet gehabt hätten, nämlich eines, was vermutlich nicht so dominiert ist von datensammelnden Werbekragen.
Naja, aber aus damaliger Sicht war das das absolute Horrorszenario, dass du für jeden Scheiß irgendwie zur Kasse gebeten wirst.
Naja, der Punkt...
Das Internet war damals noch kostenlos und die Leute haben freiwillig ihren Scheiß im Internet verschenkt. Die Zeitungen sind alle ins Internet gekommen, haben ihre Artikel einfach reingestellt.
Klar, bloß die hätten halt... Also in dem Augenblick, wo man gesagt hat, okay, das machen wir jetzt erst mal und dann haben wir halt irgendwie eine Methode, um irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein hundertstel Cent pro Artikelklick zu nehmen auf bestimmten Seiten, hätte zu einem anderen Internet geführt, nämlich einem, wo du für Dienstleistungen, die du in Anspruch nimmst, direkt bezahlst. Und man hätte es auch damals schon anonym bauen können. Also es wäre halt mit irgendwie... Xiaomi und E-Cash gab es damals schon. Es war jetzt also nicht so, also so um 2000 drum wäre es überhaupt kein Problem gewesen, technologisch halt so ein Internet zu bauen. Das wäre durchaus möglich gewesen.
Aber es wäre nicht im Interesse der Firmen gewesen. Die wollten ja sehen. Die wollten auch damals schon sehen, wer ihre Leser sind.
Ja klar. Aber das ist halt so ein Punkt, wo man sagen kann, wenn es so ein System damals gegeben hätte, würde die Welt heute anders aussehen. Das ist halt so, aus meiner Sicht, das Zweite ist halt...
Ja, es ist aber nur aus heutiger Perspektive, ist das nicht so schlimm, wie das, was tatsächlich passiert ist. Damals haben wir das andersrum gesehen. Also ich erinnere mich an Diskussionen...
Also wir haben darüber diskutiert damals, aber ich weiß ziemlich genau, dass ich gesagt habe, Micropaymentsysteme sind besser als dieses Datenkrankentum, was wir jetzt gerade haben. Weil dann hätte man nämlich, also wenn in dem Augenblick, wo es halt irgendwie keine... Also wo die wirtschaftliche Notwendigkeit des Datenkrankentums nicht begründbar gewesen wäre, wo man nämlich gesagt hätte, also wenn man sagen könnte, okay...
Das war doch nie ein Widerspruch. Warum sollen die denn ein anonymes System ausrollen, wenn sie auch eins ausrollen können, womit Kreditkarte, wo sie sehen können, wer du bist. Die würden doch noch bescheuert, wenn sie den zusätzlichen Werbemarkt irgendwie weggelassen hätten. Das ist ein feuchter Traum, den du da gerade träumst.
Naja, Moment. So der zweite Aspekt wäre, und dann hätten wir halt damals schon an dem einen Punkt sagen müssen, okay, wir brauchen jetzt aber wirklich mal mehr Regulierung und wir müssen uns darum kümmern, dass der Datenschutz tatsächlich auch im Internet stattfindet, weil er kann dann eben stattfinden, weil du eben diesen inhärenten Konflikt von du hast gerade keine Möglichkeit, den Business ins Internet zu bringen, weil du keine Finanzierungsmöglichkeit hast, außer Datenkrankentum, den hättest du halt nicht gegeben. Also ich meine, selbstverständlich kannst du dir einen Google vorstellen, wo du 1.000 Cents pro Sucheanfrage bezahlst. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Also wäre vollständig denkbar, machbar, wäre technologisch realisierbar.
Das heißt doch nicht, dass die keine Werbung einblenden. Wie kommst du darauf?
Na, weil du dann halt sagen kannst, dann geh ich halt woanders hin. Dann trag ich halt mein Geld, das was ich bezahle, zu dem Dienstleister, der halt irgendwie es nicht tut.
Das kannst du jetzt schon machen und das tut keiner.
Dann hättest du einen Markt gegeben.
Den gibt's doch.
Nein, gibt's nicht.
Guck mal, wie viel Marktanteil DuckDuckGo hat. Es gibt einen Markt aus den Maschinen.
Du bezahlst DuckDuckGo ja auch nicht.
Ja, weißt du, das ist doch ein Argument für meine Seite, nicht für deine. Selbst wenn es nichts kostet, ja wenn du kein, wenn es nicht, guck mal.
Wir haben uns daran gewöhnt, wir sind, wir sind da.
Nein, ganz wirtschaftlich gesprochen hat Google, hat Google ja einen Vorteil und kann billiger anbieten, wenn sie meine Daten auswerten, ja. Als DuckDuckGo, die sie nicht auswerten, wenn du jetzt von Mikrotransaktionen ausgehst. Das heißt, wenn du in einer Welt, die du sie gerade skizzierst, sagst, dann gibt's einen Markt und die Leute können zu DuckDuckGo gehen. Ne, tun sie jetzt schon nicht, wo es gleich viel, nämlich gar nichts kostet. Also ich glaube, das ist kein Argument, dass du sagst, dann können die Leute ja...
Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment. Was ja damals passiert ist, ist ja, dass die... Also wieso Google ja so groß geworden ist, war, dass damals Alter Vista, als dominierende Suchmaschine, halt technologisch grob verkackt hat. Na also, die haben es halt einfach nicht hinbekommen, halt irgendwie einen Search-Ranking zu bauen, was irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise so gut war, wie das von Google. Das, was Google da heute macht hat, mit dem von damals wenig zu tun. Ich würde tatsächlich, muss ich sagen, das mittlerweile Search-Ranking von Google signifikant schlechter, als das von Doc.Go. Also es zeigte einfach wesentlich mehr immer von demselben Bullshit an, den irgendwelche Search-Engine-Optimierer da irgendwie auch in Webseiten gekodet haben. Davon hast du dann die ersten fünf Pages voll. Ich klick mittlerweile teilweise schon so auf die fünf oder die sechs irgendwie, wenn ich Google benutze, damit ich relevante Resultate bekomme und nicht den Quatsch, den mir sich da irgendjemand hinoptimiert hat. Und dann haben sie halt mit der Werbeeinblendung in die Suchresultate halt ein Business-Modell gefunden, was ist zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo wir eine Menge Sachen hatten, die damals schon denkbar waren, wie zum Beispiel ein Tierfutterversand. Kannst du nicht wissen, ob du den noch drein einladen kannst? Da gab es großes Gelächter drum, dass irgendwie, keine Ahnung, petfood.com oder pet.com oder so an die Börse ging, so kurz bevor der ganze Laden explodiert ist. Jaja, da sieht man mal, was das für ein Wahnsinn war. Wer würde denn schon Tierfutter im Internet kaufen?
Na, alle Leute, wie es sich rausstellt.
Wie es sich rausstellt? Alle Leute. Und woran sind die damals gescheitert? Und wieso haben wir dann irgendwie Amazon an den Hals bekommen, als irgendwie eben diesen einzigen Großlogistiker? Weil die die ersten waren, die eine Payment-Relationship wirklich in den Griff bekommen haben und die verstanden haben, dass friktionsloses Durchführen der Dienstleistung, das ist, was die Leute belohnen, was die Leute wollen, also wofür sie halt in der Regel bereit sind, wiederzukommen. Und da war halt genau der Punkt, wo halt, wo die Sachen schiefgelaufen sind. Und was wir halt damals nicht verstanden haben, was wir jetzt im Nachhinein sehen können, ist, dass in dem Augenblick, wo einer dieser Konzerne einen konsistenten Vorsprung hat, wird dieser Vorsprung nicht mehr kleiner, sondern immer nur noch größer, weil sich eine Technologieführerschaft einstellt, die dann am Ende auch zu so unvorhergesehenen, die Venture Capitalisten sagen, dazu PIVOTS führt. Also ich meine, Amazon, wir schimpfen alle immer auf Amazon, jetzt halt irgendwie, weil irgendwie Arbeitsbedingungen in den Versandzentren. Amazon könnte aus rennen Profitgründen halt irgendwie problemlos sagen, sie gießen diesen Versand irgendwie, ja Gott, den verkaufen wir jetzt mal an irgendjemand. Der macht halt nur noch irgendwie einen Bruchteil von deren Profit aus, die machen ihr Geld mit dem ganzen Cloud-Kram. Also es ist halt so, Amazon ist tatsächlich ein Cloud-Betreiber mit einem erschlossenen Einzelhändler. Früher sagte man immer, Siemens ist irgendwie eine Bank mit angeschlossenen Elektrohandel. Aber tatsächlich sind wir bei Amazon jetzt genau dieselbe Situation. Und daraus folgt eben aber auch, dass diese Menge Geld, die diese Unternehmen in relativ kurzer Zeit anhäufen konnten. Das sind halt irgendwie Premiere, Amazon, Google, Facebook, Microsoft und Apple. Die haben dazu geführt, dass sie halt die besten Leute konsistent heuern konnten, weil sie halt immer weiter eskalierende Gelder gezahlt haben. Dass sie in der Lage waren, halt im Zweifel Konkurrenten vom Markt wegzukaufen, weil sie halt eine überproportional große Kapitalakkumulation haben konnten. Ich meine, wenn du die Kriegskasse von Apple anguckst, die könnten mit im Wesentlichen mehrere Nationalstaaten gleichzeitig Krieg führen, und zwar physischen Krieg, indem sie halt einfach nur Mercenaries hirern. Und die wären immer noch nicht irgendwie ernsthaft irgendwie in der Situation, wo sie sich sorgen, um ihre Cash-Reservien machen müssen. Das heißt, diese Mengen an Geld, die da halt quasi nicht linear, sondern muss man schon sagen fast logarithmisch, akkumuliert werden, führen halt dazu, dass der Kapitalismus halt aus ist. Man muss halt einfach sagen, dass der Markt dann nur noch zwischen diesen Firmen funktioniert, die dann halt zu absurden Strategien greifen. Also zwischen diesen Unternehmen hast du jetzt halt so Sachen, die dann halt Seiteneffekt zum Beispiel haben, dass halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Privacy vielleicht mal wieder ein bisschen wichtiger wird, weil Apple sagt, okay, was ist irgendwie das, was Google und Facebook am meisten ärgert, ist, wenn wir ihnen die Daten von den Usern nicht geben. Also, gedreht wird...
Man könnte auch sagen, weil sie technologisch nicht konkurrieren konnten mit den billig Android-Geräten.
Würde ich jetzt als Apple-User so nicht sagen. Nee, aber die, also preislich konnten sie nicht konkurrieren. Das ist richtig, weil wir sie halt irgendwie nicht noch irgendwie 25 App-Installationsplätze für irgendwie zwei Dollar pro Platz mit deinem Datenverkauf in den Telefon verkaufen. Aber anyway, diese Strategie, die Apple da gerade fertig will, die wir als Illustration benutzen, jetzt nicht um Apple zu verteidigen, nennt sich Stealing the Oxygen. Das heißt, man dreht den anderen auf einer ziemlich hohen strategischen Ebene den Zugang zu etwas ab, was die als Grundlage ihres Businesses nehmen. Das ist was Ähnliches, was Google damals mit Microsoft gemacht hat. Also als sie Google Docs gemacht haben, Google Docs war halt so ein klassischer Stealing the Oxygen Move, weil sie dann halt gesagt haben, so naja, Herr Gott, die verdienen so viel Geld mit diesem Office-Paket. Also es ist halt irgendwie, Microsoft hat damals wirklich ja geldtankerweise verdient damit, bei den Preisen, die sie da genommen haben.
Es ist ja jetzt ein Abo, was ich ja noch krasser finde, dass sie damit durchgekommen sind.
Ja, ist eigentlich erstaunlich, ne? Aber so alle Leute, die halt gelegentlich nur so eine halbwegs gute Textverarbeitung und mal ein paar Briefe zu schreiben brauchten, die nehmen jetzt halt einfach Google Docs, weil es for free ist. Und die bezahlen jetzt halt mit ihren Daten, aber gut, so ein Docs kannst du jetzt halt nur so mittelfine Daten halt rausziehen. Aber auch ganze Unternehmen benutzen inzwischen Google Docs, weil es halt einfach okay gut funktioniert. So und letzten Endes muss man sich so sagen, so wenn du so ein Microsoft Office Start ist, irgendwie was hast du halt, ich glaube ich 32 verschiedene Server, die da irgendwie erstmal kontaktiert werden bei Microsoft, wenn du halt irgendwie nur so ein Office Start ist.
Ja, das ist bei Google Docs genauso, aber ich glaube der eigentliche Punkt ist, dass es wieder reibungslos geht. Ja, das ist alles schön integriert. Du hast dann irgendwie, musst nur den Link verschicken und dann arbeiten die Leute noch parallel am selben Dokument und so. Jaja klar, ich meine Microsoft will da ja auch hin. Inzwischen gibt es ja einen Krieg darin, wer besser sich integrieren kann in irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten. So Microsoft versucht das mit Teams gerade, mit dem ganz großen irgendwie Vorschlaghammer. Da ja.
Aber gut, also nur um sozusagen diesen Gedanken, diese Klammer einmal zuzumachen. Die Konkurrenz zwischen diesen großen Firmen führt halt dazu, dass die Strategien, die die da fahren, massive Auswirkungen auf den normalen Alltag haben. Also das ist halt so wirklich, als wenn Großmächte Krieg führen. Weil die User sind mehr oder minder zwangsläufig, und weil es die meisten, die sind halt gefangen in diesen Ökosystemen und sind dann halt davon abhängig. Und wer glaubt, okay, ich hab hier alles Open Source, dann guckt euch doch mal an, wo Mozilla sein Geld herkriegt. Und dann guckt euch doch mal an, was da gerade für einen Desaster mit Thunderbird gelaufen ist und welchen Zusammenhang das damit hat, wie viel Geld Google da hinschippt und wofür dieses Geld verbraten wird. Ist so, dass die sich da vollständig unabhängig von zu machen, ist selbst irgendwie als Hardcore-Open-Source-Enthusiast inzwischen einigermaßen schwierig geworden. Und deswegen sind diese Auseinandersetzungen halt auch so wichtig. Und deswegen sind halt dann eben auch die Momente von Regulatory Capture, wo halt diese Unternehmen halt starten, als ihre Gehilfen benutzen, halt so wichtig geworden. Also ich meine, Apple stellt sich halt hin und sagt so, naja, also GDPR, finden wir eigentlich eine gute Sache, solange es Facebook schadet. Natürlich tun sie das, logischerweise. Das ist halt so ein Ding, wo ich vermute, sie irgendwann sogar auf den Geschmack kommen und sagen, okay, und dann lobbyen wir auch noch in Kalifornien und sonst nur in Amerika dafür, dass irgendwie im Wesentlichen GDPR übernommen wird, solange es Facebook schadet. Nicht weil sie irgendwie glauben, dass wir jetzt irgendwie Privacy verdient hätten, sondern weil deren Business-Strategie ist halt, ja deine Daten sind eh nichts wert, wir haben den Geld schon.
Naja, das müsste ja nicht so bleiben. Sie könnten ja auch morgen anfangen, die Daten weiter zu verkaufen. Ich glaube, wenn sie sich da eine Chance ausmalen würden gegen Facebook, würden sie das auch tun. Aber haben sie halt nicht. Facebook hat einfach so viel Marktmacht. Ja, aber naja, das führt auch zu so anderen Effekten, wie wenn sich die Unternehmen beiden irgendwas einig sind, wie zum Beispiel, dass du als Privatjurist nicht in der Lage sein solltest, deine Endgeräte zu reparieren. Dann kannst du halt völlig vergessen, dass irgendein Staat da auch nur den Mund aufmacht. Das ist gerade so ein Kriegsschauplatz, weil es so einige Vorstöße gab von wegen, das könnte man doch mal gesetzlich regeln. Oder die EU debattiert jetzt seit Jahren, ob man nicht mal vorschreiben sollte, dass es für Geräte Updates gibt für eine bestimmte Mindestzeit. Nicht mal das kriegt man durch, was ja eigentlich offensichtlich sein sollte. Wo man eigentlich annehmen würde, dass der Markt das schon regelt, aber das tut er halt nicht, wenn es alles so Riesenmonopolisten sind.
Na gut, da muss man halt sagen, sind die... Also ich glaube, dass mit den Updates ist eine Sache, wo inzwischen die großen Hersteller eingesehen haben, dass es eigentlich auch in ihrem Interesse wäre. Nur, dass halt durch die Struktur des Marktes, also wenn du halt diesen ganzen Android 2 anguckst mit diesen ganzen China-Devices, ist Google da jetzt auch nicht unbedingt in einer direkt beneidenswerten Position.
Aber hör mal, die liegen in dem Bett, was sie sich selbst gemacht haben, wie es heißt. Das ist ja nicht schuld von Acer.
Also mein Mitleid ist da gering. Es ist halt nur eine Diagnose der Situation. Ich meine, Apple ist in einer besseren Situation, weil sie ihre Hardware in den Griff haben und sagen können, wir können drei oder fünf Jahre Support, kein Problem, können wir halt versprechen. Aber bei so anderen Sachen, also wenn man sich zum Beispiel halt irgendwie mal Crypto nehmen, da haben wir halt irgendwie jetzt diesen interessanten Punkt, wo die MegaCorps versuchen, den Staaten nicht zu hart auf den Fuß zu treten. Im Austausch dafür, dass sie wiederum an anderen Stellen halt irgendwie mehr Liebe bekommen. So also und früher war es ja so, dass halt so, also dieser ganze Bereich Crypto Wars, den hatten wir ja glaube ich 2013 oder so was zuletzt besprochen.
Der ist wieder frisch auf der Agenda.
Genau und schon wieder, schon wieder, immer noch so.
Das ist so eine Eiterblase, die vor sich hin blubbert. Da müsste mal jemand irgendwie rangehen mit einem sterilen Instrument.
Ich denke, es ist halt wirklich so dieses Konzept von Forever Warner, also halt so Kriege, die halt niemals enden können, weil sie halt irgendwie eine eigene Dynamik entwickelt haben. Ich glaube, das bei den Crypto Wars inzwischen auch so.
Ist ja auch ein fundamentaler, irgendwie nicht kompromissfindbarer Konflikt, den es da gibt. Wir haben auf der einen Seite irgendwie Leute, die Geräte benutzen und denen gerne vertrauen wollen würden. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du halt den Staat, der sagt, wir dürfen euer Telefon abhören, wenn du Drogendierer bist. Also möchte ich auch dein Telefon, Smartphone, irgendwie abhören können, wenn du Drogendierer bist. Und ich glaube, das eigentliche Problem bei dieser ganzen Menge Lage ist mal wieder der Vertrauensverlust an den Staat, von dem wir mit dem wir angefangen haben, aus genau dem Grund. Weil einfach niemand mehr dem Staat das glaubt, dass das dann nur für irgendwie Drogendierer benutzt wird oder sagen wir für Terroristen. Eigentlich ist ja immer die Rhetorik so irgendwie für Mörder und Terroristen. Und dann wenig später gibt es irgendwie Kopierschutz über Rechtsabmahnung. Deswegen, ja, so insofern glaubt den einfach auch keiner mehr ihre Beteuerung. Und deswegen sind die Fronten so verhärtet, dass es auch niemand willens ist, denen auch nur einen Schritt entgegenzukommen.
Das mit dem Niemand stimmt halt eben nicht mehr. Weil die die Situation ist ja die, dass wir...
Da kommen wir zu den großen Korps wieder, wenn der Staat sagt, pass auf, wir regulieren dich jetzt, außer...
Nee, das sagt der Staat nicht mal. Ich glaube, es ist halt einfach eher so, dass der, also wenn man sich so die Auseinandersetzungen guckt, wenn das FBI mal wieder an den Telefon entschlüsseln will. Irgendwie so, regelmäßig so, dass die dann halt da eine PR-Kampagne fahren und sich irgendwas ausdenken, weswegen sie jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Apple oder Google dazu zwingen müssen oder Microsoft Daten rauszurücken. Meistens irgendein Terrorfall oder irgendein anderes dramatisches Verbrechen.
Nur der Terrorist kann uns sagen, wo er die Bombe hinterlegt hat.
Genau.
So Bullshit-Szenarien, die sich immer als falsch herausstellen.
Ja, und wenn wir ihn schon nicht foltern dürfen, dann wollen wir wenigstens sein Telefon lesen. Was da halt ja passiert war, dass Apple sich hierhin gestellt hat und gesagt hat, so, wir machen unsere Verschlüsselung nicht schwächer. Woraufhin das FBI halt zu einer israelischen Firma gegangen ist, sich von denen einen Export gekauft hat, das Ding aufgemacht hat, und die Daten halt schon hatte, als sie weiterhin versucht haben, Apple öffentlich irgendwie dafür zu erpressen. Aber was im Zuge dieser Geschichte auch passiert ist, was sehr viel weniger Öffentlichkeit bekommen hat, ist, eigentlich wollte Apple einen Feature ausrollen, was in ihrem gesamten Universum halt fehlt, nämlich das iCloud-Backups, also iCloud ist Apples Cloud von Telefonen, die back-upen sich normalerweise einfach regelmäßig in die Cloud. Hat halt den großen Vorteil, dass du halt nicht irgendwie über dein Telefon verloren hast, musst dich halt mal dein Passwort erinnern, kannst dein Telefon genauso wieder restoren, kann man auch alles lokal machen, musst halt nicht in die Cloud machen, aber fast alle Leute machen es defaultmäßig in die Cloud. Diese Backups sind nicht so verschlüsselt, dass Apple da nicht reingucken kann oder Apple auch nicht die Daten rausrücken kann, aber sie könnten es tun und sie haben es sogar schon fertig entwickelt gehabt. Aber sie haben es nie ausgerollt. Sie haben offensichtlich, also zumindest ist es die Nachrichtenlage, auf Wunsch des FBI, bzw. auf Druck des FBI darauf verzichtet, ein Feature auszurollen, wo man sagen würde, ok, eigentlich ist das aber eine Sache, die der Markt will. Also man ist doch eigentlich ein völliger No-Brander. Natürlich möchte ich nicht, dass irgendwie der Staat in meinen Backup gucken kann, selbst wenn es irgendwo in der Cloud ist.
Oder Apple. Also wir wollen nicht so tun, als wenn nur der Staat hier böse Dinge tut, ja?
Wer auch immer. Also eigentlich würde ich, dass niemand in meinem Backup gucken kann.
Außer dir selbst.
Außer mir selbst, genau. Und ein ähnliches Muster haben wir irgendwie auch bei Google, wo die Einflussoperationen offensichtlich ein bisschen anders funktionieren. Also mir wurde zugetragen, dass es halt im Wesentlichen halt nur mit Eric Schmidt anfing, der damals halt irgendwie Google CEO war, glaube ich, ja. Der halt irgendwie quasi so diesen ganzen Geheimdienst und Staatskomplex da bei Google angefangen hat reinzubringen, was jetzt halt darin sich fortgesetzt hat, dass etliche Ex-Geheimdienstler und ehemalige Behördenleute halt irgendwie bei Google arbeiten. Und es führt dann halt dazu, dass regelmäßig Projekte, die dazu führen würden, dass Google in Daten nicht mehr reingucken kann und damit auch der Staat in Daten nicht mehr reingucken kann, gekillt werden. Also alles, was irgendwie Hardening über einen bestimmten, über einen bestimmten Bereich hinaus angeht, findet halt einfach nicht statt, wird halt einfach nicht, die Plot wird nicht ausgerollt, weil es da halt eben die wahrscheinlich sogar sehr explizite Übereinkunft mit dem Staat gibt, dass solche Systeme halt nicht zu sicher sein dürfen.
Ich finde dieses Narrativ sehr gefährlich, weil es nämlich den Eindruck erweckt, als seien die MegaCorps eigentlich auf unserer Seite.
Nein, sind sie nicht.
Naja, also dem würde ich gerne entgegentreten und zweitens würde ich gern nochmal den Finger in die Wunde legen, dass selbst wenn Apple jetzt so ein Feature hätte, könnte ich oder du als User das nicht prüfen, ob das wirklich so ist. Ja, das heißt, die können behaupten, was sie wollen, wenn der Tag lang ist. Dieser Art von Versprechen ist erst mal nur das, ist ein Versprechen. Ja, das weißt du erst, wenn das FBI es versucht hat und gescheitert ist, dass es nicht ging. Oder dass das FBI inkompetent ist, das kann natürlich auch sein. Also was ich zu diesem Apple-Fall gehört hab, ist, dass das FBI sogar Zugriff auf den iCloud-Backup hatte von dem User und dann irgendwas verkackt hat und deswegen wollten sie noch mal irgendwie als Vorwand. Also es war nicht mal so, dass sie an die Daten nicht eh rangekommen wären. Das heißt, die Parteien lügen auch noch alle in unsere Richtung. Und ich würde gern den, die, die, wie sag ich mal, das Vorurteil ausräumen wollen, dass es nur das FBI ist, was uns anlügt. Die großen Konzerne lügen uns selbstverständlich genauso an. Das heißt, das Herstellen einer Situation, bei der es besser wäre, dass man als End-User prüfen kann, dass die Daten tatsächlich für niemand anders lesbar sind, ist aber nicht so einfach. Ja, weil das setzt eine gewisse, wie soll ich sagen, Literacy, sagt man auf Englisch, ja, sondern man muss der Anwender sich halt mit der Komplexität der Situation zumindest so rudimentär auseinandersetzen. Und das kann man im Grunde von den meisten Usern nicht erwarten. Das heißt, unsere Diskussionen sind so ein bisschen akademisch hier, finde ich immer. Wir haben zwar inhaltlich recht, aber selbst wenn sich da jetzt fundamental was ändern würde, wäre das für den End-User im Grunde nicht erkennbar.
Nee, aber was wir jetzt halt haben, ist die Situation, dass die Staaten, wo sie jetzt da einmal Erfolg hatten mit dieser Taktik, also dass sie halt einfach irgendwie sich da halt einfach mit den MegaCorps verbrüdert haben und man halt eine Übereinkunft gefunden hat, die nach außen hin so aussieht, als würden die MegaCorps sich dann doch ein bisschen um die Sicherheit kümmern und die Staaten halt trotzdem Zugriff auf die Daten bekommen, wenn sie es dann unbedingt wollen. Sind die Staaten jetzt halt an dem in dem Ding eins weiterzugehen, zu sagen so ja, und dann wollen wir eigentlich aber auch noch die Sachen, die ihr schon jetzt zufällig irgendwie starker verschlüsselt habt. Also halt zum Beispiel Messaging und sowas, also dass sie halt einfach sagen, okay, wir müssen halt irgendwie Kindesmissbrustdarstellungen irgendwie automatisch rausfiltern können. Und wenn das schon geht, dann dann wollen wir halt in der Lage sein, halt irgendwie, dass wir auch irgendwie Urheberrechtsverletzungen verhindern. Nee, erst mal kommt noch Terrorismus. Das ist immer die heilige Dreifaltigkeit. Fängt ja immer mit Kindesmissbrustdarstellungen an. Dann geht es mit Terrorismus weiter. Dann ist wahrscheinlich, als ich vermute, dann kommt erst mal noch so Steuerhinterziehung, damit nicht alle so laut schreien. Und vielleicht noch ein paar Nazis oder so. Und dann kommen wir erst zu Copyright. Also das ist halt so. Also man muss halt schon die Dramaturgie einhalten, sonst ist es vielleicht auch ein bisschen auffällig. Aber dieses Prinzip, was wir jetzt halt sehen, was versucht wird, durchzudrücken, wird seit ein paar Jahren ventiliert, kommt halt primär so aus Richtung der Briten interessanterweise, die da halt wieder mal den Stadthalter der Amerikaner in Europa spielen.
Die machen ja auch die Technologieführerschaft innerhalb der Five Eyes, war so mein Eindruck, wenn es um Abwärmen geht.
Bei einigen Sachen schon, ja. Und die nennen das dann halt verantwortungsvolle Verschlüsselung oder auch Responsible Encryption. Ja, natürlich Verschlüsselung ist wichtig, ihr könnt natürlich alle gerne verschlüsseln, so haben wir kein Problem, es ist auch gut für die Sicherheit und so. Aber außer alle, außer manchmal, dann wollen wir halt irgendwie, dass unser Entschlussungs-Schlüssel mit hinzugefügt wird, damit wir halt irgendwie in der Lage sind, halt irgendwie da irgendwie mitzulesen, so. Und wenn man das aus dem Workflow und des Geheimdienstes herausdenkt, macht das ja auch total Sinn. Weil die arbeiten sowieso den größten Teil des Tages über Metadaten und wenn sie dann ein automatisches Interface hätten, wo sie den Leuten, die aus den Metadaten interessant aussehen, sagen können, okay, und jetzt tun wir mal halt irgendwie zu dem, keine Ahnung, iMessage-Interface irgendwie oder zu dem Google-Message oder WhatsApp oder was auch immer, Interface von den Leuten, die aus den Metadaten als interessant rausfallen, halt noch eine zusätzliche Entschlussungskey rein, der ist doch besser für alle Beteiligten, weil dann hätten sie immerhin den Vorteil, dass die Russen nicht dasselbe tun können, außer sie hacken das Interface.
Naja, also da gibt es zwei Anmerkungen, die ich gerne machen würde. Erstens, das ist alles uralt, das ist schon aus den 90ern. Der Fachbegriff für was die jetzt gerne hätten bei Verschlüsselungssystemen ist Key Escrow. Und Escrow kommt von Bankkonten eigentlich. Also da geht es darum, ein Konto zu haben und wenn du ein Haus kaufen willst, dann zahlst du da die Kohle ein und dann gibt es eine trusted third party, irgendwie ein Notar oder so, der guckt sich das an, bestätigt dem Hauseigentümer, dass die Kohle auf dem Konto ist oder bei großen Transaktionen zwischen großen Firmen macht man das auch. Und wenn dann der Vertrag unterschrieben ist, dann wird die Kohle aus dem Escrow Konto übertragen. Und die Idee ist jetzt, dass man mit kryptographischem Schlüsselmaterial dasselbe macht, dass man sagt, okay, das wird jetzt halt nicht auf ein Konto überwiesen, aber es gibt eine trusted third party. In diesem Fall halt die Polizei oder die Geheimdienste. Und die haben eine Kopie von dem Schlüssel, den du benutzt, um deine Sachen zu verschlüsseln. Und wenn jetzt wirklich Not am Mann ist, dann kann man da halt hingehen und mit dem Schlüssel deine Daten entschlüsseln. Aber das Problem ist halt, das kannst du auch sonst dann halt tun, wenn nicht Not am Mann ist. Ja, wir haben jetzt so ein paar schöne Skandale mit dem Zeigern.
Moment, ich muss da inhaltlich was korrigieren. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Also das Verfahren, was sie da vorschlagen, heißt nicht Key Escrow, wo halt die Schlüssel hinterlegt werden.
Nein, aber das ist das alte Verfahren.
Genau, sondern das heißt Additional Key Decryption. Das heißt also, man versucht zu sagen, sie wollen halt auf Anforderungen in der Lage sein, einen ihren zusätzlichen Schlüssel hinzuzufügen, der dann halt die Daten, also quasi einen Group Chat, in dem dann halt irgendwie noch zusätzlich sie der Dritte sind, auch wenn es eigentlich nur zwei Personen sind.
Ja, das Problem an der Sache ist, die möchten das natürlich auch rückblickend haben, nicht nur auf jetzt laufende Geschichten. Also die möchten schon eigentlich auch haben, dass sie deine liegenden Daten, also zum Beispiel deine Mailfolder, deine Backups lesen können. Und das geht nur, wenn du beim Verschlüsseln schon an einen zweiten Schlüssel auch verschlüsselt hast. Und dann sind wir beim selben Effekt wie KeySCrow. Also die Ideen sind alle alt und neu, aber es werden jetzt halt neue so Ablenkungsmanöver gefahren, damit es klingt, als sei das was Neues. Aber die Idee ist alt. Und die Argumente dagegen sind auch alt. Das erste wäre, wir haben jetzt ein paar schöne Polizeiskandale gehabt im letzten Jahr, wo rauskam, dass irgendwelche Polizeibeamten irgendwie Datenbanken einfach benutzt haben, um da, sagen wir mal, eine Liste von Antifa-Leuten zu suchen und es den Nazis zuzustecken oder so. Also, dass Leute, die rechtlich gesehen berechtigt waren, auf die Daten zuzugreifen, die halt missbrauchen. Oder ein aktuelleres Beispiel ist dieser Nawal Nifal. Der hat einfach im Internet Fluggastdaten gekauft. Und es stellt sich halt raus, in Russland sind die im freien Zugriff der Polizei. Und wenn du so und so viel, irgendwie 100.000 Polizisten im Land hast, da finden sich halt ein, zwei Korrupte drunter, die das dann im Darknet verscheuern.
Wahrscheinlich ein, zwei tausend Korrupte.
Ja, also ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie, das soll jetzt hier nicht unser Thema sein, welches Land korruptere Polizisten hat. Aber der Punkt ist jedenfalls, wenn du eine offizielle Möglichkeit einrichtest, über die auf Daten zugegriffen werden kann, dann wird das mit einer Sicherheitgrenz der Wahrscheinlichkeit missbraucht werden. Und das ist nicht irgendwie eine schlechte Voraussage, sondern da haben wir, dass das schon so passiert. Also das ist bekannt. Ja, und die andere Sache ist, das ist nicht der einzige Ansatz, den sie durchdenken. Es gibt noch einen anderen, nämlich, dass man einfach irgendwie Trojaner und Backdoors installiert. Und da gab es eigentlich auch gerade einen schönen Fall bei Juniper. Das ist ein Routerhersteller. Da hat die NSA dafür gesorgt, dass einer der Zufallszahlengeneratoren kompromittiert ist. In öffentlichen Standards. In Amerika gibt es sowas wie DIN-Standards, das heißt der NIST. Und NIST hat ein Standardaufbitten der NSA gemacht, der von dem inzwischen bekannt ist, dass da eine Hintertür drin war. Das ist schon länger vermutet worden. Und es stellt sich raus, Juniper hat den tatsächlich ausgeliefert. Und dann kam raus, dass bei Juniper fiese Hacker eingedrungen sind und die Hintertür ausgetauscht haben. Sodass die Hintertür, mit der eigentlich die NSA euch alle abhören wollte, dann eben für die Chinesen oder wer auch immer das war, offen stand. Und das ist eine Sache, die auch von Anfang an klar war, dass das eine Bedrohung ist. Und es ist jetzt eben nicht nur eine theoretische Bedrohung, sondern es ist auch tatsächlich passiert. Wir sind jetzt also in der eigentlich glücklichen Lage, dass wir hier nicht mehr spekulieren müssen, sondern wir wissen, dass das die Risiken sind. Und wir wissen, dass es da keine Verteidigung gegengibt, jedenfalls in der Vergangenheit nicht gab. Also die Annahme, dass es in Zukunft dann verteidigbar ist, ist auch sinnlos. Ja, das ist nicht so.
Naja, und wir haben halt irgendwie die Situation, dass die, wenn denn einmal sowas etabliert ist, also wenn du halt sagst, okay, du baust halt so Systeme halt in die Massen verwendeten Produkte ein, weil natürlich halt irgendwie die MegaCorps wollen natürlich irgendwie, wie es immer so schnell ist, Good Corporate Citizens sein. Also die wollen ja nicht sich vorwerfen lassen dann in der Bildzeitung, dass sie jetzt halt irgendwie Kinderschänder decken. In dem Augenblick entsteht natürlich halt ein sehr viel größerer Druck auch auf Nischenanbieter halt, wie irgendwie Signal oder Freema oder so, die halt dann easy von genau denselben Journalisten halt irgendwie als diejenigen, die halt sich nicht an diese neuen Regeln halten, dargestellt werden. Und irgendwie, wer auch immer gerade der Feind des Tages ist, halt irgendwie die decken und schützen und irgendwie da halt irgendwie die Kriminalität befördern. Wir sehen jetzt halt zum Beispiel auch, dass die Europol fängt jetzt teilweise sogar an, VPN-Anbieter zu durchsuchen mit der Begründung, dass darüber halt irgendwie Ransomware-Kommunikation gelaufen sei. Also so Sachen passieren jetzt halt gerade. Also wir sehen halt so einen Allfrontenangriff auf gesicherte, verschlüsselte Kommunikation, wo halt quasi so dieser Impetus, der dahinter steht, ist zu sagen, ja, also Verschlüsselung ist so lange gut, wie du halt nichts irgendwie Illegales darüber machst. So in dem Umblick, wo halt wir auch noch die Vermutung haben, dass du irgendwas Illegales darüber machst, hast du halt irgendwie deine Rechte verwirkt. So das ist halt so dieser Ansatz, der da halt hier vorgetragen wird. Und der halt, muss man auch sagen, von irgendwie nicht ganz kleinen Teilen, der technologisch eher, sagen wir mal, nicht so bewanderten Politiker unterstützt wurde. Und bis weit hinein auch zum Beispiel in die Grünen. Also was ich da zum Teil erlebt habe, in Diskussionen mit Politikern, die dann halt aber spätestens in dem Augenblick, wo man dann sagt, aber die Kinder hat man dann halt irgendwie sofort so. Aber wie kann denn es sein, dass irgendwie die bösen Menschen jetzt Verschlüsselung benutzen dürfen? So das dürfen die doch gar nicht dann da kommen. So das ist halt so ein Ding, wo dann in dem Augenblick, wo halt, sagen wir mal, so eine enge, ja, wie sagen wir mal, so ein Staatsoligopolismus da ist, wo halt irgendwie große Unternehmen, jetzt nicht nur die Interne Unternehmen, sondern irgendwie alle, die halt eine bestimmte Größe überschreiten, halt eine so enge Verzahnung mit dem Staat eingegangen sind, dass es halt ein vollständiges, schon vollständig vermaschtes gegenseitiges Abhängigkeitsverhältnis ist, dass dann halt einfach es halt wirklich sehr, sehr schwer wird, halt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, Freiheitsrechte auch noch zu verteidigen.
Also meines Erachtens das schönste Beispiel, wo das so richtig mal auf den Punkt gebracht wurde, war vor inzwischen auch schon wieder so zehn Jahren oder so, bei der Gesundheitskarte. Da ging es dann darum, wir machen jetzt zentrale Infrastruktur und da war dann plötzlich einer der Werbepunkte für deren Hosting, dass es in einem beschlagnahmesicheren Stahlkäfig sei, die Server. Das heißt, da hat uns die eine Hand des Staates erklärt, keine Sorge, die andere freidrehende Hand des Staates greift uns hier nicht in die Tasche.
Bayern.
Naja, also sie haben jetzt nicht gesagt, wie sie damit meinten, aber so die Bedarfsträger, nicht? Nennt man das im Jogong. Und ja, das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem. Auf der einen Seite ist das ja auch, die Argumentation ist ja nicht völlig absurd, die die bringen. Natürlich, wenn du irgendwie einen sicheren Kommunikationskanal hast, natürlich wird ja dann von Kriminellen auch benutzt werden. Wir haben gerade so einen Fall gehabt, dass ein Schlag gegen ein verschlüsselndes Messenger-System gelungen ist, mit dem sie dann irgendwie vier- bis fünfstellig Drogenkriminelle hops genommen haben, weil die halt das alle benutzt hatten. Ja klar, das stimmt, aber auf der anderen Seite sind wir hier in einem Rechtsstaat und da gilt die Unschuldsvermutung. Und im Zweifelsfall muss man ein paar Verbrechen hinnehmen in einem Rechtsstaat, wenn die Alternative ist, dass du jemanden foltern müsstest oder andere Grundrechte einfach mit Füßen trittst. Es gibt halt eine Schranke und der freie Zugriff auf kryptographiegesicherte Informationen ist eben jenseits dieser Schranke. Das ist das Gegenargument. Also wir bestreiten ja auch nicht, dass man damit nicht Kriminelle fangen könnte. Das wird so sein. Nur die kann man halt auch anders fangen, stellt sich raus.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass wenn man so ein bisschen versucht, dass sie mehr in die Motivation reinzusteigen, warum Tunstaaten das, warum sind die irgendwie so in diesem Paranoia-Trip? Ich glaube, die haben halt einfach Angst vor Kontrollverlust in dem Sinne, dass sie wissen, dass die wirtschaftliche Lage mit diesen zunehmenden Oligopolen und der immer stärkeren Spaltung der Gesellschaft in irgendwie sehr reiche und so mittelarme Leute dazu führen wird, dass sie halt immer mehr halt irgendwie unter Druck geraten und halt irgendwie auch immer mehr Leute einfach kriminell werden. So ganz klar, wenn halt irgendwie die Gesamtmenge an Geld, die halt im Umlauf ist, sinkt und die Realenkommen sinken ja immer weiter und auf der anderen Seite halt irgendwie die Vermögen von den reichen Leuten halt immer höher werden. Das ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass immer mehr Leute auf die Idee kommen werden zu sagen, ja dann hole ich mir doch mal was davon. Und da wird es dann halt für den Staat halt einfach auch einfach zur Systemfrage zu sagen, so okay, wir müssen halt irgendwie überall reingucken können, weil wir nicht dulden können, dass sich halt irgendwie Machtzentren auch auf unsere Einflusses bilden.
Ja, nur ist das Machtzentrum ist ja nicht der kleine Mann, der über irgendwie Facebook Messenger kommuniziert. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, da muss ich hier mal kurz eine These ausrollen, dass die Opfer ihrer eigenen Propaganda geworden sind. Es gab ja diese ganzen farbigen Revolutionen, wo es dann immer hieß, die haben sich über Facebook irgendwie abgestimmt. Und damit ist ja nicht gemeint, dass es da eine Facebook, eine öffentliche Facebook-Gruppe gab, sondern damit ist der Messenger gemeint oder irgendwelche Closed User Groups. Und das ist ja genau das, was die jetzt gerne aufmachen wollen. Oder lasst es von mir aus WhatsApp sein. Aber die Propaganda war eigentlich in allen Fällen, die haben sich über irgendwelche Internet-Messenger ausgetauscht. Und das glauben die natürlich auch, die Politiker, wenn sie das selber verbreiten. Das gehört doch dazu. Ja, damit du eine Sache, das wissen wir spätestens auch seit Jesminister, mit so einer Sache gut der Presse erklären kannst, musst du sie selber glauben.
Das stimmt. Ich glaube, es geht sogar noch ein bisschen tiefer, weil da sind ja durchaus auch Leute unterwegs, auf Seiten der Staaten, die ein bisschen längere Perspektive haben und die glauben, dass der Staat das Einzige ist, was zwischen uns und dem Chaos steht. Also dem Abgleiten in so Warlord-Fail-State-Szenarien.
Du meinst so was wie Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, so viele Warlords haben wir da, glaube ich, noch nicht.
Ja, wir haben so gewisse Polizeinahe, Schützenverein, Gruppen, die...
Ich rede von eher so was von so echte Fail-Stats wie Somalia oder sowas, wo es halt keine wirkliche staatliche Autorität mehr gibt. So was in so einer Szenarien sind natürlich für solche Leute halt auch aus der Perspektive, man muss sich ja nicht immer was Böses unterstellen. Das ist ja so, das sind halt viele Leute, gerade bei Law Enforcement und so unter den Politikern, sind halt irgendwie viele Leute unterwegs, die sagen, der einzige Weg zu verhindern, dass wir in so einen Chaos abgleiten, in so eine vollständige Unsicherheit, ist halt ein starker Staat, der den Bürger vor diesen ganzen Unbilden der Welt da draußen beschützt. Und dazu brauchen wir Kontrolle.
Das brauche ich nicht, dass die Bürger beschützen wollen, die wollen sich selbst beschützen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Da gibt es wirklich so Leute, die zumindest, glaubt würde ich sagen, klar will ich halt irgendwie meine Karriere, klar will ich halt irgendwie, dass meine Behörde größer wird und klar will ich halt irgendwie, dass irgendwie will ich halt auch Macht und Einfluss haben. Aber meine Grundmotivation ist halt, dass irgendwie sozusagen, weswegen man überhaupt angefangen hat, ich meine, man muss doch mal überlegen, warum gehen Leute irgendwie in den Staatsdienst. Jetzt sagen wir, außerhalb von Lehrern, wo es halt alles Idealisten sind, aber halt so die, so Leute, die halt einfach dahingehen und sagen so, ich will die Welt besser machen, gibt es ja durchaus einige. Und bei denen ist halt dieser Glaube zu sagen, ein guter Staat ist ein starker Staat, der seine Macht im Sinne seiner Bürger einsetzt. So, das ist halt so dieses, dieses Postulat, was es da gibt. Und natürlich erodiert es über die Zeit und wird halt immer zynischer und halt immer weiter von der Realität entfernt. Und so klar, aber ich glaube, dass...
Außer es geht gegen Steuerhinterzieher, dann ist der Staat plötzlich machtlos und kann nichts tun.
Wenn sie groß genug sind, ganz wichtiger Punkt. Erst, also eigentlich gilt es erst so ab so 10 Millionen ungefähr, da drunter bist du auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall, bist du auf jeden Fall Feindbild. So, also, so, aber ich glaube, was die halt wollen, ist halt irgendwie dieser, diese Kontrolle. Also da kann man Manuel Castells, der es halt so als einer der ersten ganz gut zusammengefasst hat, da geht es halt darum, um die Kontrolle von Flüssen, also von Flüssen von Leuten, von Waren, von Geld, von Informationen. Und diese, die Kontrolle dieser Flüsse ist halt Macht, also dafür sorgen können, dass bestimmte Dinge nicht verkauft werden können, dass bestimmte Geldströme nicht stattfinden können und so weiter und so fort, ist halt Macht. Und wenn man sich so anguckt, was die Regierung machen, so sowas wie irgendwie die ganze Geldwäsche-Gesetzgebung, dieses irgendwie immer weitere Einschränkungen von Bargeld, also was, weswegen sie sagen halt, wir wollen weniger Bargeld, weil irgendwie die bösen, schlimmen Kapitalisten da drüben hinterziehen halt Steuern, weil sie halt ganz viel Bargeld-Transaktionen machen. So ja, die Glaubwürdigkeit, die Glaubwürdigkeit solcher Aussagen ist halt stark eingeschränkt. Aber tatsächlich ist dieses, und da muss man auch wieder sagen, sind Journalisten halt durchaus mit Schuld dran, weil sie halt natürlich gerne halt dann irgendwie, wenn sie halt sowas wie die Panama Papers oder so in die Hände bekommen, da hast du halt auch Einblick in eine Welt von diesen MegaCorps, wie die halt einfach Steuern in riesigen Maße hinterziehen. Nur die daraus folgenden Regelungen, die da halt irgendwie rauskommen, treffen halt wiederum nicht diese MegaCorps, weil die halt einfach zu groß, zu schlau und zu mächtig sind, um sich von solchen Regeln halt irgendwie beeindrucken zu lassen. Sondern das trifft dann halt am Ende wiederum nur die, die halt eigentlich nur so mittelgroßen Problemen sind. Also die halt, keine Ahnung, ein Mittelstädter, der halt mal eine Million oder so hinterzogen hat. Herrgott, so wenn du irgendwie anguckst, du hast Amazon nicht an Steuern zahlt oder Google nicht an Steuern zahlt.
Oder die Cum-Ex.
Genau, oder halt so irgendwie mal 50 Milliarden aus der Staatskasse direkt absaugt. Da fällt einem dann halt auch nicht mehr so viel zu ein so. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, da sind Leute unterwegs, die sagen, okay, wir wollen halt eine stärkere staatliche Kontrolle und wir wollen mehr Einblick und wir wollen mehr Möglichkeiten für den Staat zu agieren und an Informationen zu gelangen. For the greater good. Die glauben wirklich daran, dass sie diejenigen sind, die halt irgendwie recht haben und dass der der Staat die Antwort darauf ist, dass die Welt schlecht ist.
Und das Problem ist aber auch eine Form von regulatory capture, finde ich. Das ist so. Ich bringe immer Bergwandern als Beispiel dafür. Wenn du nicht in der Lage bist, dir selbst einzureden, dass das System so ist, kannst du es nicht zu Ende führen. Du kannst nicht Politiker werden, wenn du dich nicht vorher davon überzeugt hast, dass die Politiker die Guten sind und dass sie an der Lösung der Probleme interessiert sind und dass die Polizei auf ihrer Seite ist und integer und nicht korrupt ist. Das ist eine Lebenslüge einfach. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum man die nicht vom Gegenteil überzeugen kann, egal wie viele Fakten man hat. Das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Gegenbeispiele sind dann halt einfach nur Einzelfälle.
Genau, bedauerliche Einzelfälle.
Toll, die Einzelfälle sind.
Lustige Blog-Serie draus.
Tja, und ich glaube, dass halt irgendwie dieses, was wir jetzt halt gerade sehen, so diese neue Auflage der Crypto Wars, insbesondere halt irgendwie mit Kinesis-Boss-Darstellungen und halt irgendwie mit diesen oder jenen Kriminellen, wie wir sie jetzt irgendwie bei dieser EncroChat-Geschichte haben, wo sie halt irgendwie jetzt ein paar 10.000 Kriminelle hochgenommen haben.
Das ist natürlich ein tolles Argument für Crypto-Hintertüren.
Genau.
Schau mal, wie viele Kriminelle man da auf einen Schlag ausräuchern kann.
Ich meine, sie haben da de facto halt irgendwie größere Teile der, sei mal nicht ethnisch orientierten, transnational organisierten Kriminalität gesehen. Also das ist halt so, weil die haben das offensichtlich alle benutzt. Und die wurden dann jetzt plötzlich einmal sichtbar. Und jetzt sind die halt irgendwie an dem Punkt, wo sie sagen, so ist ja ein bisschen mehr, als wir uns so gedacht haben. Und wir kommen gar nicht mehr hinterher.
Aber jetzt mal aus einer anderen Perspektive. Der einzige Dienstleister, bei dem du sozusagen weißt, dass er keine Hintertüren eingebaut hatte, ist dieser kriminellen Dienstleister. Denn die anderen Dienstleister werden jetzt gesetzlich verpflichtet, Hintertüren einzubauen. So, da wird sich doch der kriminelle Dienstleister nicht dran halten. Das heißt, die Einzigen, die einen Nachteil durch die Regulierung haben, sind die anderen Leute. Und an der Stelle ist vielleicht auch der Hinweis auf die Crypto AG nochmal angebracht. Das ist so eine Schweizer Firma in Besitz von einem Schweden gewesen. Die haben Kryptogeräte an fremde Regierungen verkauft und da waren Hintertüren drin in einer Kooperation zwischen CIA und BND. Das ist alles schon seit Jahrzehnten gerüchtet worden und jetzt ist das nochmal so richtig hochgeschwappt. Bei der Gelegenheit kam dann raus, die Schweizer wussten es und haben es geschehen lassen. Es kam raus, es gab noch eine zweite Firma, von der die Schweizer dann ihre eigenen Geräte gekauft haben und da waren auch Hintertüren drin. Das heißt, wir können im Wesentlichen davon ausgehen, immer wenn irgendeine Regierung irgendwo drin ist, ist das Datenschutzniveau geringer, als wenn es die freie Wirtschaft macht. Da ist es schon echt scheiße, weil im einen Fall ist es bloß Inkompetenz, im anderen ist es halt Bösartigkeit. Das heißt, im Grunde kannst du keiner Seite trauen im Moment und daher setzen auch die meisten Cryptografen sowieso auf Open Source, damit man eine Chance hat, das zu auditieren, aber das ist halt keine skalierende Lösung. Die gute Antwort gibt es noch nicht. Die ganzen Software-Systeme sind auch alle so komplex geworden, dass der wahrscheinliche Angriff gar nicht durch die Krypto geht, sondern durch ein Software-Bug drumrum. Die Situation ist schon generell eigentlich nicht so, dass es ein Problem wäre. Aber da möchte ich auch noch mal kurz reflektieren. Ich habe ja vor vielen Jahren... Ich hab mal mit Microsoft gestritten, als ich vor Ort war und da irgendwie rum auditiert hab und hab mit den Security-Leuten da gestritten, was denn jetzt der richtige Ansatz sei, um die Software zu, um die Situation zu verbessern. Und die Microsoft-Leute haben sich entschieden, was ich damals absolut scheiße fand, lauter Mitigations zu machen. Das heißt, die haben nicht den Bug verhindert, sondern sie haben das Ausnutzen von dem Bug teurer gemacht. Und ich fand das damals scheiße, weil ich fand, das hält eigentlich so die Hobbyisten unter den Sicherheitsforschern ab, die Bugs zu finden. Und dann werden wir eher weniger Bugs finden. Aber heute muss ich sagen, wenn das Bedrohungsszenario eben tatsächlich die Staaten sind, dann hat Microsoft mich und die Staaten damals ausmanövriert erfolgreich, weil sie es geschafft haben, dass jetzt die Dienste gerade feststellen, oh, Exploits kaufen ist ja richtig scheiße teuer. Also so gesehen haben die völlig recht gehabt, das muss ich rückblickend sagen, dass mein Bedrohungsszenario da vielleicht auch zu weit gefahren ist.
Warte, jetzt habe ich den Logo noch nicht ganz verstanden. Also du sagst halt, dass die Mitigations, also so was wie Stack Protections und Memory Address Randomization und solche Sachen, versuchen generell, das Exploiting auf den Systemen härter zu machen, dass die dazu geführt haben, dass die Preise für die Exploits gestiegen sind.
Ja, das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Exploits waren früher überhaupt nichts wert. Und dadurch diese Mitigations ist ein Markt entstanden. Und heute kostet so ein schöner Remote-Bug im iPhone siebenstellig. Und so ein Bug hält ja nicht ewig.
Und meistens nicht nur ein Bug, sondern halt eine Bug-Kette.
Ja, du brauchst eine Bug-Kette, genau. Aber der Punkt ist, wenn man sich also in einer Situation halten will als Geheimdienst, der immer so ein paar Exploits für alle wichtigen Plattformen auf Halde hat, das ist richtig kostspielig. Ja, und ich glaube, dass Microsoft da vielleicht mehr gesehen hat als ich. Ja, weil ich dachte, irgendwie die Bedrohungen sind irgendwelche, was ich, russischen Kinder.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, jetzt wird es interessant, weil, weil das heißt ja, also sozusagen, also deine Theorie ist ja, dass zumindest, sagen wir mal, auf den, den großen Mainstream-Plattformen, also wir reden jetzt mal nicht von dem ganzen Giraffe, halt hier, wie so SolarWinds und so, aber auf den großen Mainstream-Plattformen, dass die Software-Sicherheit so weit gestiegen ist, und die Exploits so teuer geworden sind, dass es für die Geheimdienste wichtiger geworden ist, oder absehbar sich wichtiger wird, weil es dauert ja ein paar Jahre, bis sie ihre Wünsche umgesetzt bekommen haben, wieder direkten Zugriff auf die verschlüsselte Kommunikation zu bekommen, weil sie absehen können, dass Trojaner auf den Endgeräten schwieriger wird. Das ist doch eigentlich deine These, ne?
Naja, Trojaner ist jetzt so ein...
Oder, oder......Exploits werden schwieriger.
Trojaner...
Zugang zu den Systemen bekommen, um den Cleartext auszuleiten, bevor es verschlüsselt wird.
Genau, ich glaube, dass wir jetzt gerade diese Diskussion über Backdoors haben, weil eben das Hacken zu teuer geworden ist, was jahrelang eben das Mittel der Wahl war.
Aber ich seh... also meinst du wirklich meine sieben Stell... Ich entschuldige mich, also ein iPhone Exploit kostet gerade was? 1,5 Millionen und 2 Millionen oder so?
Naja, aber guck mal, du wendest ihn einmal an, dann ist er potenziell weg. Oder vielleicht ist er auch weg, bevor du ihn einwendest.
Naja, also ich meine, guck dir heute gerade den letzten NSO-Hack an, die halt irgendwie offensichtlich eine Kette von funktionsfähigen iMessage-Exploits hatten. Zum Teil halt Zero-Click, das heißt, die haben halt einfach eine Message geschickt und dann hat dein Telefon einen Exploit-Code nachgeladen. So was gibt's immer noch. Ja, aber der war Monate unterwegs und dann wurde er auch immer wieder geupdatet offensichtlich. Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass ich da so Gefühle erstellte, bei denen herrscht da Dürre oder so.
Na, das weißt du halt nicht aus Sicht des Dienstes. Du musst davon ausgehen, wie bei Stuxnet, dass das irgendwie in die freie Wildbahn gelangt, wenn das irgendwie eine Exploit-Funktionalität hat und dass dann irgendein Arschloch bei irgendeiner Anti-Viren-Company, das irgendwie zur Rufaufbesserung analysiert und deine Exploits alle verbrannt sind. Und ich glaube, diese Unsicherheit, die das früher war, war wirklich überhaupt keine Dürre an Exploits. Da gab es einfach Mailing-Listen, wo jeden Tag irgendwie 10 bis 100 Exploits rumkamen. Und das ist echt viel weniger geworden durch diese ganze Mitigation-Geschichte. Was nicht heißt, dass die Software sicherer geworden ist. Das ist der Teil, den ich immer kritisiert habe.
Nur das Exploiting ist härter geworden.
Vielleicht ist das ja tatsächlich egal. Vielleicht ist es tatsächlich wichtiger gewesen, dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie die Dienste sich Sorgen machen und langfristig lieber gesetzliche Backdoors einfordern. Weil dann kämpfst du wenigstens so ein bisschen mit offenem Visier. Weil dann kannst du einfach aufs Gesetz zeigen und sagen, ja hör mal.
Okay, also ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob diese These zutrifft. Also wenn ich jetzt zu mir so angucke, was so die Trends sind bei staatlichen Exploits, dann sehen wir halt so drei Sachen. Zum einen sehen wir, wir finden Sachen immer erst ziemlich spät. Also die sind immer Monate unterwegs, oder teilweise Jahre unterwegs, auch auf Mainstream-Plattformen, bevor sie gesehen werden. Zum anderen sehen wir einen Trend zu In-Memory, Memory Resident Exploits, die automatisch, also ohne User Interaktion funktionieren. Das heißt also, was die halt machen, ist, die sagen, wir schreiben gar nicht in den Flash, wir wollen nichts hinterlassen, was ein Auditor finden kann, sondern wir laufen nur in Memory. Wir exploiten die Basement-CPU oder wir nehmen irgendeinen von den anderen zwei Dutzend Prozessoren unseres Telefonexploitens. Die benutzen die als Springboard, um jeweils wieder ins Hauptbetriebssystem reinzukommen. So eine Sache. Und zum dritten, Automation. Ganz viel Automation. Das heißt also, du hast dann nicht mehr irgendwie dieses, da sitzt dann halt so ein Team, was dann halt irgendwie dir handcraftet über einen Link, halt irgendwie den Exploit-Unterschied, sondern du hast halt einfach eine Maschine, der sagst du Go und dann findet die halt einen Weg, dir irgendwie den Telefon aufzumachen. Also es hat es übertrieben, aber da geht der Trend halt hin.
Probiert irgendwie alles durch, was ist auf Lage?
Genau. Das eignet sich ja auch für Machine Learning, also muss man klar sagen.
Aber warum glaubst du denn, dann haben wir jetzt diese staatlichen Hintertüren als Forderungen? Ich glaube, wenn das überhaupt kein Problem ist, einfach alles immer zu exploiten.
Also naja, das ist halt die Frage, die wir diskutieren. Und eigentlich sagt mir deine These ja, deine Theorie, dass die ja halt auch länger denken, weil bis wir jetzt halt dahin kommen, dass wir halt staatliche Hintertüren wirklich ausgerollt in den Geräten haben und die irgendwie alle eingeknickt sind und halt irgendwie die dieser Zugriff dann auch funktioniert und irgendwie gesetzlich zugelassen ist und die Geheimnisse und Regeln bekommen, das dauert ja so drei bis fünf Jahre. Und das passiert dann nicht nächstes Jahr. Also selbst wenn die Gesetze nächstes Jahr beschlossen werden, bis das dann halt alles wirklich passiert, dauert das halt alles so. Das ist noch so Grandfather Claus. Genau, das wissen die natürlich auch. Was halt wiederum heißt, dass die Diskussion jetzt wieder hoch zu kochen, wenn man läuft jetzt so seit anderthalb, zwei Jahren so in unterschiedlichen Anläufen, heißt, dass also eine mögliche Interpretation dessen ist, dass die Angst vor genau dem Szenario haben, was du skizziert hast, nämlich dass die generelle Exploitbarkeit der Mainstream-Plattformen so stark abnimmt, dass sie nicht mehr sicher sein können, dass sie immer eine volle Exploit-Pipeline haben. Wäre eine mögliche Interpretation. Ich bin noch nicht so ganz sicher, ob die zutrifft. Weil dazu sehen wir halt einfach zu viel. So links und rechts und vorne und hinten und irgendwie hier so. Und ich meine...
Na ja, aber guck mal, das ist ja dasselbe Problem wie in der Security generell. Du als Verteidiger musst immer alles abwehren und der Angreifer muss nur an einer Stelle durchkommen. Und in dem Fall ist es so, dass wir sehen halt die erfolgreichen Angriffe. Wir sehen ja nicht, dass die vorher ein Jahr probieren mussten.
Das stimmt. Ja und natürlich ist halt noch eine weitere mögliche Motivation ist halt dieses No one but us. Na also dass man halt sagt, so eine Additional Key Decryption ließe sich im Zweifel so absichern, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Russen die permanent hops nehmen und nicht nur ab und zu, ist halt irgendwie... Ja super, großartig... .ist halt irgendwie darstellbar. Und es würde dir ermöglichen, sagen wir mal, reineren Gewissens in IT Security zu investieren, weil du sagst, ok, du hast ja den Zugang schon als Geheimdienst, weil du hast ja eine additional key decryption und als Strafverfolgungsbehörde und du bist jetzt nicht darauf angewiesen, dass die Systeme weiterhin unsicher bleiben.
Das wird mir gerade ein bisschen zu wieselig, was du da formuliert hast.
Na ja, Moment, Moment, das war eigentlich total logisch, ne? Weil du, also wenn man es mal brutal formuliert, heißt es, additional key decryption würde es halt möglich machen, dass die Geheimdienste und die Strafverfolgungsbehörden plötzlich rein herzensführend mehr IT-Security sein können. Wäre jetzt halt so eine, so eine These.
Ja, das ist aber auch schon, schon länger eine Sache, die ich, die ich mich frage, weil die werden ja auch alle Nase dann gehackt. Ich, was ich gerne wirklich mal wissen würde, ist, wie viel Polizei von Ransomware runtergefahren wurde, irgendwelche örtlichen, weil da habe ich noch nichts von gehört und das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das die einzigen sind, bei denen es nicht passiert. Auf Mailklicks irgendwie, das würde ich gerne mal wissen. Wie viele Datenbanken da schon irgendwie. Das wäre doch mal richtig geil. Stell dir mal vor, wenn eine von denen von den... Also ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie irgendeine von diesen Datenbanken, über die wir hier immer irgendwie, die wir von denen wir finden, die hätten nicht da sein sollen, dass sie dann von der Ransomware verschlüsselt wird, weißt du? Dass uns die Ransomware von den staatlichen Übergriff schützt. Das wäre doch mal ein Szenario für ein schönes Sci-Fi-Buch. Ja, wir wollten diesen Typ Hops nehmen, aber der Folder mit den Beweisen ist leider veransomwert worden.
Du meinst so eine Art Robin Hood Ransomware, ja?
Ja, na gar nicht mal irgendwie mit Heerenmotiven, sondern einfach eine ganz normale Ransomware. Aber verschlüsselt halt die Daten, die dir wertvoll sind. Und das wäre in dem Fall eben die Datenbanken über die Bürger.
Ja, kommt bestimmt noch. Aber erstmal scheint ja der Trend zu sein, dass sie nicht nur reine Ransomware mit Verschlüsselung machen, sondern die Daten vorher ausleiten, damit sie die halt irgendwie dann, falls das Opfer nicht zahlen will, im Zweifel publishen können.
Oder auch wenn das Opfer gezahlt hat.
Oder auch wenn das Opfer gezahlt hat. Und den Punkt reinzureimen, dass sie zu spät gezahlt haben oder so.
Ja, wir hätten uns hier noch ein bisschen Trinkgeld erwartet.
Fehlte aber die Transaktionsgebühr.
Ja, also es sieht alles nicht so gut aus.
Ja, aber gut, ich finde, das war das Jahr 2020.
Ja, das ganze Jahr. Aber ich finde es wichtig, als Lektion zu sagen, dass wir als einzelne Bürger im Wesentlichen ein Spielball zwischen zwei Seiten sind, die uns beide nichts Gutes wollen. Weder die MegaCorps noch die Regierung haben unsere Interessen im Sinn. Und der einzige Ausweg ist, dass man sich selber aus seiner selbstverschuldeten Unmündigkeit befreit, indem man IT-Knowhow anhäuft. Das würde ich gern allen ans Herz legen, als vielleicht fürs neue Jahr sich das vorzunehmen.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich zwingend notwendig, dass man die Fähigkeiten und Fertigkeiten sich zumindest rudimentär selbst zu schützen und zu verstehen, was die Probleme sind und wie die eigenen Daten genutzt und gegen einen verwendet werden können, dass man da halt noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit und Aufwand reinsteckt. Inzwischen ist es halt auch so, dass irgendwie die Ressourcen dazu ja auch irgendwie echt viel besser geworden sind. Also selbst wenn man halt nur How-to-Videos nimmt, also wie konfiguriere ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, meinen Home-Router so, dass er halt irgendwie als Werbeblocker dient, zum Beispiel, oder stelle ich mir noch einen Raspberry Pi und knödel mir den so dazu, dass er halt irgendwie als mein heimatlicher DNS-Server dient und halt verhindert, dass irgendwie Google mich die ganze Zeit abschnorchelt, solche Sachen, kann man halt durchaus alles lernen. Das ist jetzt auch alles nicht so superschwierig mehr, weil irgendwie auch immer mehr, muss man sagen, Open-Source-Projekte halt darauf achten, dass sie halt einfach zu benutzen und installieren sind. Das ist halt schon... Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass deren Softwarequalität durchgehend besser wird durch die ganzen UI-Frameworks, die sie sich dann halt noch dazuholen, aber zumindest führt es dazu, dass halt irgendwie ihre Benutzbarkeit und wahrscheinlich damit auch ihre tatsächliche Nutzung steigt.
Na, und die Fundamente wären halt tatsächlich im Allgemeinen besser. Das muss man auch wirklich sagen.
Echt, was ist dazu? Also ich weiß nicht, ich hab irgendwie so jetzt so...
Also es gibt jetzt, das ist inzwischen echt rar, dass es mal ein Remote Code Execution in irgendeinem Kernel gibt. Das kommt immer noch vor, aber es ist wirklich selten.
Stimmt, in den Körnern ist wirklich selten. Aber ja, auch in den TCP-Stacks ist es mittlerweile auch eher selten geworden. Stimmt.
Ja, also RPG und OpenSSL haben zwar immer noch gelingtlich Sachen, aber das sind dann eher so akademische Geschichten. Also es wird besser. Es ist nicht so, dass es gut ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser, als es früher war.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und man muss auch sagen, dass das ein bewegliches Ziel ist, mit dem wir hier arbeiten. Also in der Security ist es so, dass immer mehr Bug-Klassen jetzt anerkannt werden und bekämpft werden. Also zum Beispiel war es früher völlig wurscht, wenn eine Software abgestürzt ist, bei schlechtem Input. Hat man gesagt, garbage in, garbage out. Ja, dann musst du sie halt mit richtigen Daten füttern. Jahrzehntelang war das so. Und inzwischen ist das anerkannt, dass eine Software nicht abstürzen sollte, auch wenn du sie mit Müll fütterst. Da musste man früher argumentieren, heute ist das anerkannt. Ja, das nächste Kapitel ist, dass man out of bounds Reads prinzipiell vermeiden möchte. Das ist gerade noch so ein bisschen, da muss man noch teilweise argumentieren. Ja, also normalerweise ist es so, so die typischen Bugs, mit denen man Codausführungen auf fremden Geräten erreichen kann. Das sind normalerweise irgendwelche Speicherkorruption. Das heißt, da wurde irgendwo hingeschrieben, wo man nicht hätte schreiben sollen. Ja, man will irgendwie zum Beispiel, man liest eine Nachricht aus dem Netz und erwartet höchstens 100 Zeichen und dann kommt 200 rein. Und wenn man den Code so gemacht hat, dass man es nicht prüft, dann schreibt man mehr als man Platz reserviert hatte und das kann ausgenutzt werden. Wenn man jetzt mehr liest, als man reserviert hatte, dann kriegt man halt irgendein Müll zurück. Das heißt, das ist so eine Bug-Kategorie ähnlich, wie unindizialisierte Variablen und so. Das haben viele Leute immer noch nicht auf dem Radar, dass man das trotzdem auch fixen sollte. Aber es wird besser. Das heißt, wenn jetzt der Eindruck entsteht, als wenn wir immer noch genauso viel Bugs haben wie früher, dann stimmt das. Aber die Anzahl der Sachen, die wir als Bugs sehen, hat sich halt auch vermehrt. Das heißt, unterm Strich fange ich langsam an, auf meine alten Tage so ein bisschen so was wie Optimismus zu kriegen.
Ernsthaft?
Das ist demnächst irgendwie, ja, naja. Also, ich meine, die Zukunft, wie heißt das so schön? Vorhersagen sind schwierig, besonders über die Zukunft. Aber meine Beobachtung ist, wir finden immer noch viele schlimme Bugs, aber die werden inzwischen auch gefixt. Also, das ist tatsächlich seltener, zumindest in meinem persönlichen Erfahrungsumfeld, dass Leute anfangen, rum zu argumentieren. Und wenn sie argumentieren, dann nur noch bei einigen Arten von Bugs. Ja, inzwischen ist es zum Beispiel so, dass man sagt, wenn du irgendeine Kryptographie machst, dass du danach den Speicher clearn solltest, damit da keine Daten versehentlich irgendwo noch rumgammeln. Das war auch jahrelang eine Sache, haben die Leute gesagt, ja, aber wenn der Angreifer so weit kommt, dass er meinen Ram auslesen kann, ist eh vorbei. Genau. Und diese Art von Perspektive auf Bugs hat sich echt verschoben in den letzten Jahren oder Jahrzehnten, würde ich sagen. Das ist eine längerfristige Sache. Und vielleicht wird es ja doch irgendwann besser. Aber wir haben halt immer noch so Sachen, wie die Leute setzen dann Open Source Jitsi ein. Und das ist halt noch ein relativ junges Projekt. Da gibt es dann halt auch noch so Kinderfehler. Also es ist nicht so, Open Source ist nicht gut darin, mal eben schnell was aus dem Boden zu stampfen. Das ist auch kommerziell nicht gut drin. Da muss man vielleicht auch einfach gucken, dass man die Erwartungshaltung irgendwie in einem gesunden Bereich hält. Aber so grundsätzlich ist es schon so, wenn jetzt irgendein Open Source Produkt, sagen wir mal, sich mit TLS verschlüsselt, dass man dann da nicht irgendwie reingucken kann, da kann man sich schon drauf verlassen inzwischen. Oder, was weiß ich, also da hätte ich sogar mehr zutrauen, dass Open Source zum Beispiel beim Updater keinen Mist macht, als irgendwelche selbst updaten, in den Commerzsoftware-Geschichten. Weil bei Open Source läuft das normalerweise über die Distros und die haben alle ordentliche Signaturen. Also, verallgemeinern ist natürlich immer schwierig, aber also mein persönliches Fahrgefühl ist besser geworden, würde ich tatsächlich sagen in den letzten Jahren. Da hab ich schon das Gefühl, dass mehr Leute auch auf mehr Sachen achten.
Super, dann haben wir tatsächlich doch mal einen optimistischen Schluss, deswegen werd ich dir jetzt mal nicht widersprechen.
Zum ersten Mal in 20 Jahren.
Ein optimistischer Schluss aus dem Jahr 2020. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Kommt irgendwie gut ins Jahr 2021.
Ich hoffe, dass es besser wird als das Jahr 2020.
Dass es besser wird, genau. Und falls ihr Lust habt, wir haben doch noch irgendwo so einen Patreon-Button, wenn ihr draufklicken wollt, müsst ihr aber nicht. Und dann alles Gute und bis zum nächsten Mal.